Okay.
Focus on your life so you can let your dreams come back to you.
No, I don't want to play any more.
Go back real.
Save your dreams.
It took 1,000 years to perfect the battle machine.
But it's only a second to pull the trigger.
Good morning.
Last morning, you got the Atlantic Sea?
You don't watch the sea?
Yeah.
Well...
Sorry, game's still out, game's still out.
Return back to the...
To what? To speak?
Oh my god. Make phones in my arms.
Okay. Well good morning.
Good evening. Good afternoon.
Have fantastic news.
I slept.
Oh my god.
The fucking Christmas party.
Uh...
I also...
Also give him an animal.
Give him an animal. Oh.
So now I no longer have the belly of someone that has 5 days old.
Uh...
Shit.
Basically...
Can we finish the Yumi camp?
Sorry, this was a disgusting thing I could probably ever see.
And it's first thing in the morning.
Um...
Basically started after the Yumi...
Oh yeah. Oh no, this can't be.
Put me on easy. Come on.
Current levels. Suffer the silence.
I can't pick anything else.
Oh no.
Oh no, this can't be.
Creatin' you? Oh no.
We can only pick make warrior.
We have to do normal difficulty.
We can't just do camp.
Right, anyway.
Very quickly summarized what happened.
After the fantastic Yumi plus collab,
which was an absolute hoot and holler,
turns out we all love each other.
Um...
I basically passed out
for six hours.
And then I woke up and I was like...
Ugh, my stomach, my stomach.
Ugh, I can't do this anymore.
So I give him an innermot
and I did that.
And I ended up...
I ended up passing out
again after that.
And I woke up with five minutes to go.
So all in all,
I ended up sleeping 12 hours.
I woke up with a massive headache.
That's not gonna stop me. I'm taking painkillers.
Turns out I am...
I freaking...
But I accidentally hydrate
via my fucking ass.
Because it didn't come out at first.
And I was like, excuse me?
Water? Where did you go?
Hmm...
Um, so that was actually taking room.
No.
Uh...
The good news is...
We're playing...
It's technically a childhood game,
but I was actually too weak
to play this at any point.
So I know of,
you know, all the mech
types and all of that.
Because I watched my dad play this game, basically.
So I don't even know if we're gonna successfully
get through it, but it doesn't matter.
Because we're gonna try our best.
I do have a ASMR
membership stream planned.
As well, at the end of this.
Now, if we do get hard stuff,
uh...
My plan is to throw mech
assault out the window, and then
I'll just do my membership.
Eh...
Take time for your health.
Literally,
I kid you not, I should have played this
when my...
When my dad gets here.
Because he could unironically...
He plays...
Uh, you know what?
I'll remember the map when we get on it.
The last map, as Atlas,
he absolutely adores
and the other one, he absolutely adores.
There's one where you can, like, level all the buildings.
And...
So, my dad...
He's a wee bit, like,
mean, he's a wee bit autistic, but he doesn't realize it.
And he used to play the same map
over and over again, and did the exact same thing.
Same thing, over and over again. It's rather adorable.
Can you change the difficulty
if you're creating your profile?
No.
It's just, like...
Oh my god, axes!
Viva la France!
Eh...
Yeah, it doesn't want to do anything.
Just stay back facing them.
I mean, I guess...
Yeah.
Whoa! Okay, I guess I just...
Oh wait, current levels
suffer this silence.
It's not much of a sufferage.
I'm guessing this is, like, corporal
ranks, because in this mecha game
you are...
Um...
You'll never guess what.
You're piloting a mecha!
Ah!
What are the odds?
Um...
But yes, sorry, I'm just waking up a wee bit.
Oh, aces!
Snowberries!
No, I'm piloting a mecha!
Mech asshole!
Oh my god!
This is both their fault.
Shut up, Isla.
I'll jump in it right now.
Hi!
Snowberries!
Guten Morgan!
I'm currently slurping on my little teeth.
And then we're going to jump into this game
called Mech Assault.
It is an Xbox original!
Not even Xbox...
Not even Xbox 360!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This was an Xbox
No...
Wait!
Wait a minute!
This is the early...
The first mission!
Ooh!
It has a lady pie!
Hi, AC!
I think she's going to be resting.
And then hi, Snowberries!
We're playing Mech Assault, we're about to go speak to
the lady!
Now, you might notice my title is the most bizarre thing
you've ever fucking read out of context.
We took part from the heavy Mechs
to fix the Cougar Scout Mech!
Um, well, yeah!
Wait, what time?
I'm going to drink my tea.
Hey, sport, you ready?
I've got our orders.
The invasion still steps off as planned.
We're not paying us to be late.
But the best part is that we get to go in first.
Just like old times.
The Intel boys say the enemy is powering up
a set of nasty, ground-to-orbit guns.
If those are online when the rest of the dragoons arrive,
everyone dies.
And we blow our bonus.
So our little team gets to make a covert landing
outside the range of the existing guns,
sneak across half a continent,
and take them out before our dropships show up.
I think it's Loki, we play first.
Me?
Wait, is that Logan?
That makes me call Logan.
Wait.
Wait, so that's the intro.
So then, eating dirt is the first mission.
All systems normal.
We're in the pipe. Touchdown in two minutes.
Oh my god. It's like a pixel on my screen.
We've been scammed.
Weapon fire inbound.
Lieutenant Foster, how did they detect us?
Alpha, Bravo landers.
Prepare to hot-drop.
I want you out of this grave now.
Brace yourselves, boys. We're going in.
Is this the first mission?
Or am I picked the wrong one?
Wait, these are...
Wait.
Why does it say select mission,
and I keep getting fucking...
The operation is off to a bad start,
but the Icarus is not granted.
Our job will be much harder.
Why do I keep getting cutscene?
Okay, this is the first mission.
Here's a quick status report.
Alright, it's Cougar Scout Mac.
I knew it was Cougar.
I knew it was Cougar Scout Mac,
because of this voiceline coming up.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Holy...
Holy moly.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my PC's ready to catch fire
because it's kind of...
weird thing.
Okay.
So, there's a hidden multiplayer...
So, this game used to be multiplayer,
and there's a hidden function in it.
Oh, yeah, be safe.
There's three baddies.
Oh, my God, my PC's ready to catch fire.
If I randomly go offline,
you know exactly what.
Right.
Oh.
Are they so brave?
Why are you coming up against them, then?
Look at the size of me.
Oh, my goodness.
Right.
So, the thing about NCT 2
is you can just walk on it.
Oh.
I don't know if you can hear that.
They're going up.
Oh.
Right.
Next.
Why...
Why changes?
Okay.
Next.
Is that a ship?
I think he's glitched out.
Oh, right.
It controls the ammo type by X, Y, and Bravo.
A trained mech of work.
Destroy it.
Weapons. Use your left trigger
to cycle through the weapons,
or just...
It's official.
They know we're here and they will be coming for us.
Coming back for more?
Oh, my God.
Be sure to secure any sound that you find.
The game audio is so loud.
Ah.
Right.
So, we want music down
and we want sound down,
so you guys can actually hear the in-game ending.
How's this?
I don't know why my mic is acting
all quiet all of a sudden.
It's normally like, I'm so freaking loud into it.
I'm feeding it through the thing.
How's that?
Kind of.
How's that louder?
Well...
I see a max gain right now.
Filters.
Gains.
Okay, this is up by 14 decibels now.
Testing.
Test tickles.
Testing the tickles.
Repeat, testing the tickles.
Oh, see, these are health pads.
See that green box?
That's for health.
Maybe we were destined
for the longest collab.
Okay, it sounds much better.
Much better.
Test.
I can't remember what blues for my ultimate.
No.
So, if you lose health,
you can pick up one there.
And then, I guess,
that must be for this.
Again.
Oh, the blue must give infinite.
Oh, almost.
A new...
Attackable one.
Yeah, you literally step on them.
God, this game is actually kind of brutal for its time.
When you...
Yep.
Fucking supply convoy.
Oh, my God, my aimbot.
They never told me this game didn't come with aimbot, okay?
I'm trying not to get hit by it
because it's in the necklace.
I'm spraying.
Oh, that's the supply convoy already?
Holy crap.
Oh, my God.
I can't beat him.
I'm getting rules.
Wait.
Why was my dad so much better at this game?
No, this can't be.
Fuck the rules.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Like, I was like, way ahead of me.
Hold on.
No, there's more.
Hold on, there's enemies.
Oh, no, I'm like half health already
because I'm getting too ahead of myself.
Wait, there is aimbot on this one.
Okay, I'm staying on this one then.
Like, aimuses.
The AI in this game is brutal.
Let me heal up.
Don't make me a bad mech warrior.
Come on.
Come on, let me heal up.
There was the turret.
Come forward.
Bro, I'm trying evasive maneuvers.
They're actually not working.
I'm not being funny.
I can't evasive maneuver and aim at the same time.
Can you not destroy these?
You must. Okay, I was going to say you must.
Bro, forget.
They're leveling me. This is the tutorial.
My mech is sparking.
It's actually ogre.
It's so ogre when I started.
My mech is sparking.
Yeah.
No.
My audio is on.
I don't know what the fuck the among us collab did.
I don't know why I'm so quiet.
I can't fly.
I'm literally sparking.
Bro, we're already doing the fucking ace of marching
before I knew it.
Whoa.
You?
Okay.
Well, something just shot.
I was going to say something just shot.
Wait, hold on.
I want to use my summer heal.
Thank you, jeez.
I've got more rocket.
Oh, it's just swapped me a rock.
Oh, and you pick up the ammo tape.
It swaps you.
Fuck.
Stop it.
Oh my god, I'm actually going to lose.
I'm actually going to fucking lose.
Um, this is the tutorial.
I'm not even kidding.
Why are freaking video games so brutal?
They did not care about anyone's feelings.
Honestly, they were like,
no, you either win or you lose.
Fuck you. You have to use this thing again.
Like, where's most of these fucking things?
Sending a scout unit
and a frontal attack.
Absolutely genius.
And Diego.
Thank you for coming to member.
I'm to level this city.
I hear a chopper.
Why do I hear a chopper?
Oh, it's you.
Oh, this is mean.
People are just trying to either.
Can you aim for that?
Whoa.
Who do you think you are?
Okay, we're going for the health here.
Fuck. I knew there was a man.
No, these are...
I think these are looking.
Oh, no.
Give me the fucking health right now.
Where is it?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't do this to me.
I'm actually going to lose this tutorial.
Hold on.
Oh, my God, yes.
Oh, my God.
There's auto lock on this fucking gun type.
Oh, my God, please.
Oh, my God, I'm scared.
No, fuck it. If you fly, I'm flying.
Fuck you.
How many rockets? I've got two more rockets.
Oh, we got one. We got one.
Hold on. You're next.
Okay, we're out.
Are we? Wait.
We have infinite aim bomb.
We have infinite things and I wasn't using it
the entire time.
We have infinite aim bomb.
Missiles.
And I haven't
been using them.
Right, I need one.
Oh, my God.
Sorry, that guy was literally trying to do a
freaking development job.
What do I need to destroy?
Head cores.
Man, fuck head cores.
I think there's a hidden item
in one of these buildings, maybe?
I'm starting to be in blame to the UI.
Literally, I suck.
You have infinite ammo for all weapons.
Wait, we're just using this one, then.
Fuck up this building.
Shut up, fuck it up, fuck it up, fuck it up.
Jesus. You've actually got some
decent HP. I'll give you that, Mr.
Buildings.
There's something shooting at me.
Bruh.
Am I not...
Who the fuck is...
I love the love of what...
Ah!
Oh.
Just...
Ah!
Wait, and just like that.
Ah, right.
So we did that one.
Never doing last transmission.
Lieutenant, can you get that back?
I can't, Major. There's nothing to get back.
I see.
Any sign of the rest of Alpha Lance?
No, sir. Captain, get back
to the Icarus.
For now, it's just you and that scout mech,
but this operation continues.
Like I said, Dragoons
improvise.
Right, so we're getting our...
Oh, sorry, you can see that we missed it.
It's okay, suffering silence.
Military Defender's ability to
repel the impending invasion
by raising
their...
Home Center.
Again.
And again.
The loudness difference in this game
is crazy.
Uh-huh.
Right.
Simple.
Right, so we've unlocked the Puma,
but I don't know if it has
rockets like the other one.
Right, we'll try with the Puma.
And if we...
Puma pants,
because I do so badly with it.
We'll pick another one, thank you.
Sorry, I took way too long
on to hit the brim there.
I took way too long
to do that when I came in that joke,
so I literally just went shite myself
and then that was the joke. Right, okay.
They do seem to have some auto-lock type turret.
I'm so sorry.
But I do like this game because you can like walk into stuff
and destroy it. Like...
Excuse you!
I'm just trying to enjoy the spawn area.
That's what I'm saying. These older games are brutal.
Like, there's no such thing as like
spawn area safety or nothing.
I really strongly...
Oh.
That one just killed his own guy there.
Oh, there's a brook floor.
Oh my god,
he like fires fast.
Okay, so here's a thing
that a lot of people didn't know about.
You might notice that
I've got a heat bar on the left.
If you stand in water, your mech cools down.
And a lot of people didn't know this in the multiplayer.
So my dad used to wreck
and deck in the multiplayer
like far beyond anyone's...
like, isn't knowing
you how he was winning.
And so this was back when Xbox
headsets, like, were things
who could communicate with the enemy team
all points in the game. There were some such things
like rounds where you can smack top.
No, the entire game
someone was blasting music down the mic.
Someone was like spamming the N word
all of that stuff.
And my dad used to wreck and deck
on these bit in multiplayer.
And everyone used to be so raging at him.
They're like, hey, he's cheating. How is he doing that?
And it was because he was sitting in the water
on Alice, which is like
there's really damage in mech.
Oh.
It's like this really
damaging
a mech, but
his cooldown is like pretty
aggressive.
Oh, god, I'm gonna shut up.
All right, there. I know, those are people.
I don't really need people right now.
Where the heck did they go? Were they in the air?
I'm in the air. Fuck you.
All right, there we go.
So basically,
my dad used to wreck and deck on multiplayer.
And
the reason why I obviously like, oh, my mom
was the first E girl.
I'd say that is a joke, by the way.
Because my mom used to go and
headset and just like have a talk
with anyone. Like just like,
a lot of folks that like played mech,
had Xbox Originals at the time.
You were a working person.
You had to have internet.
You had to have the actual console,
which is quite rare in itself. Then you would have to have a game.
So it was a mature
fan base
that opted for this game.
And my mom used to go and headset
pretending like she,
so my dad used to play the game in fucking silence.
And my mom
used to like be like, oh, I just got
here.
And
my dad would be like, every morning
I'd wake up to like a billion pals
requests on Xbox.
And it makes me laugh my ass off every
time they tell me the story.
I'm like, my mom was the first fucking
girl being like,
oh, I just got you.
Like all of that down the make
and like fucking laugh.
It's such a shame.
My mom and dad made pals with
this guy from Canada.
But
it's a shame because like obviously
they never got like any contact
details of Xbox. So they never spoke.
But basically he used to get
high every day and he didn't have a job.
And my mom and
dad love talking to him because they were like,
what do you mean you don't have a job?
And there's like, oh, no, I don't need to pay
taxes and he would like tell them about Canada.
So
Grizzly, if you're out there, my mom and dad
absolutely adore you still and they still talk
to you to this day. They still remember
your game or tag Grizzly.
So hopefully you're still getting high
as hell and telling funny stories
to people in video games.
Doing Canada
proud literally.
So if you ever think like, oh,
I don't have an impact
anywhere on anyone.
Literally, there's a
Scottish man and wife that still
to this day talk about their old gamer
buddy from 20 years gone by.
It must be. I don't know how old this game is
when they were, wait, can I not?
I doubt you're flying. Coming in boys.
So yeah, don't ever be like, oh,
my life doesn't have any impact.
Like there's a
nostalgic man and woman in
Scotland that still think about you.
So, oh shit, I'm overheating. I can't
fire.
Hold on, let's get this tank
first because they're the
humans.
Yeah, when you overheat you
literally can do no damage, which is
a bit unfortunate.
Wait, what did I join into?
What's the context?
I'm just saying that even if your life
doesn't feel like it's impactful or anything
like that,
my parents
used to play
meccosal with this
random guy from Canada. They don't have this
contact information or anything, but his
gamer tag was grizzly and I'm just saying
even if you feel like your life has
no positive impact, there is
a sweet Scottish couple to this
day that still talk about this guy
that got high and played meccosal
every single day from Canada and
it doesn't, like your life
doesn't have to amount to anything
at all. That's not how it works.
And it's just very
I think it's just
Oh, there's a mecc.
Yep. Oh, I'm
seeing a battle mecc. I don't know about reading
a mecc. I just saw him.
I see him. He's coming at me like a freaking
spoon.
Oh.
Whoa, hold on.
Hold on. Is he crippled?
So mecc animations are actually
pretty decent. You can get crippled mecc
animations. Oh, fuck. I'm
overheating and there's no water nearby.
Oh, there's no water nearby.
I'm out. I'm overheating.
Hold on. Let me hide behind this building. Hold on.
Hold on, darling. Let me hide behind this
building. Okay. Okay, darling. Thank you.
Right. I've got a, I can shoot again.
Okay. He's crippled. See how
he's sparking? That's when you know that mecc
is getting weak. Yeah. He's literally on fire.
But you ready for this sound when it dies?
I'll shut up when it dies.
Oh, come on.
Whoa.
I'm one health. I'm one health in a dream.
I'm one health in a dream. I'm one health in a
dream. I wasn't paying attention. Oh, my god.
Holy. There.
Oh, my god.
I wasn't paying attention because
I was typically yattin'.
Make Grizzly only the most famous
YouTuber. Wait,
YouTuber, shut up. Imagine if it was him and
he's a YouTuber now and I'd be like,
hi, by the way, I'm the daughter of
your old best pal
that you used to talk to daily on Xbox.
What the fuck up? Could you imagine?
Is there actually someone called Grizzly on
YouTube that please make games to shut the
fuck up? Imagine. And he's the Canadian
and he gets high all the time.
So I've got some news from my dad.
Oh, my god.
Stony keeping the jet pack
that makes it overheat.
Wait, this meat. Oh, right.
It does add to your overheat. Okay.
Oh, no.
Whoa.
Wait, are you the real Stony?
Oh, thank you.
Are you kidding me?
I'm scared to go in.
Oh, it's you again.
Oh, no, it's not.
Oh, my god.
They're like sniping me from halfway
across from that.
And they have all wing.
Yeah
Oh
I think I'm supposed to have to fight in here because look how many healing stations there are
That's probably also one of the important things is to be able to fall back. Oh my god. We're just trying to hospital a
Geneva convention
Oh
Sometimes I wonder if I ever own some famous folks during my year strongy, please. What do you mean by spoon? What calling on my spoon?
It's just an insult like you can insult things
I really want to use my special ammo
Oh
And in scots you can make inanimate objects and insult
Ramblin on about yeah in scots you can make anything an insult an inanimate object an insult. Oh
Oh, we're done. Okay. Maybe there is a chance. We've finished the campaign
Resistance group actively fighting the word of Blake. We've not heard from Alpha Lance so we can use these guys help
We've seen it foster play the transmission. It's pretty rough sir seems to be repeating at short intervals
I'll let you know when I get a better read
Hey
Did we like I feel like cougar had more
Recon and light and rays from our variation of the cougar is built around the PPC
See, that's only a fucking hit that it makes friends, we'll try we'll try
The Cougar Paul, I know I'm kind of at bias
Yeah, it's an infinite input should be doable. I don't know I almost perished in that last fight because it was making a tension
Thanks
They're doing civilians
Yeah, on your way civilians or across you with my big Mac
I
Escape everyone get through the tunnel. No, don't rear end him. He's got insurance to whoa
He really says he's like hurry it on up buddy. I ain't got all day
How big your insurance cost is gonna be astronaut. I have the footage in 4k right now
I'm like one of those people that like chase them down. Whoa
Look what you've done. Look what you've done. You've derailed that poor man. Do you know how much he spends on his wee
freaking car
Yeah, I mean, you know how much his monthly expenses on a car
Shocking and look what you've done. You push that per man at that tunnel. He didn't deserve that. He didn't
Okay, I'm about to get a fight
Looks like a light scout
No, he's cheating. He's in the war. Yeah, the war
Terrorize these
We's running careful captain
Is they actually running he's not he can be
Oh, wow, I don't think I've ever noticed and I didn't even know they coded the things to run away
He actually is running away. No wait a minute. Hold on you kill civilians
So when someone has a tank that can actually do you look what happens you run away?
I'll get locked this monster on you didn't think I will she's big nice. He's sitting in the water right now ready to
Fuckin hell I'm overheating. Hold on. Let me get in the war
That's I'm cheating. I'm doing I'm doing it literally the strong and stress
Oh, come on, I can't see you when you do that hold on the hood says he's above me others
He's right there stop it. He's right there
Oh, come on in book. Come on. You can do it. You can do it. Yes
What a lovely noise
Juicy I learned it learning the dead stuff looks at least one am shot
Though is that shit, are you targeting me right now?
I've got a cross here on the map that says go this way, but I feel like I'm about to go out of bounds
There doesn't appear to be much in the area
Okay, here we go. We've got some sort of civilization up ahead. Sorry. It's just the render distance
That's all the render distance. Oh
Oh
Okay, that's honestly when she said that sorry we're doing strats
The music in this game is really good if I could put it off, but I don't know the volume
What's the word?
The volume steadiness in this game is like aged terribly because one minute
The cutscene is like blaringly loud and then the next minute is just awful
There we go
You do not I'm pretty sure the blast site does major damage so you do not want to be hanging around too close
No people it's a nuclear testing site
All right, okay, we'll head on next there seems to be some sort of tank a wee baby tank up ahead where we are. Oh
my god, wait, whoa
Sorry, I'm just trying to put something up there. There's something blue up there. Is this a secret?
All right, hold on. Let me get rid of wherever this red is
Hello, oh
It's a wee baby Mac. Okay, it's fine
It's fine
That's what we don't it cause too much destruction of core
corporation
Is this a secret? Honestly, it's like a secret. There's something blue up here
Hold on. All right. Hold on. Hold on. Let's just oh, let's just scare him this bad boy. Oh
No, it's is it
I'm sorry, but that looks like a hopscotch thing and there's something up there, but it's not registered
Well, we'll leave that I'm not but actually I will say it was really nice
They actually put a detail in the city like oh, we're a tourist site. Yeah, you should totally come see this tourist place
There's not one person around
I was gonna surprise
They just told the university
They've in oh god, there's an enemy right here, right? Yeah, come in the war come in the war
Oh, you want to be in the war so badly? Oh, you want to stay on the land whilst I stay in the war
Oh
No, no, no, that's cheating only I'm allowed in the water. Oh my god. He has a fucking all century. Fuck you
That's been awful. Oh shit. Oh
Shit, what is this always? Oh
No, it's definitely not always
It's taking him down though, whatever
Okay, let's just do that again. He's getting low. Let's just spam spam some some
There we go
Cuttlefish at home in the war literally he didn't stand a chance of some sort of enemy a tank in the war I
See this Johnny
Stranny lore comes in handy for this game type literally come into the water, you know, you want to
I
Unfortunately have no recollection or recollection of any of this. Oh, it's another mech. I see on the HUD. You see that
bomb
Square
into the water
Unless there's water ahead of me. Oh
Oh, he's coming to the left. Oh, he's trying to give me the jump right hold on if the AI is gonna come to me
I'm gonna jump in the war again. So he's coming. He's coming
There he is
Yes
Now I would do siren singing but as you all know the best I can do is some mech singing
Plunk plunk cling flying. I'm a mech
Plank flying flying
Something
It's not a mech. Thankfully, I'm getting a bit
I know literally
Collateral must be expensive on these jobs. Literally. What's that video? Whoa, you came out nowhere. You're still in the building
Are we done
Oh, I like this
Feel
Sorry, this one's really stuck in my head right now
It's just the part where it goes on
How many missions does this game have cling flying? I'm a mech
You want to come into the water?
Right hydration check
Okay, mission briefing. We're in range to target a mage. My headache is gone. Thanks to the painkillers
We take out the ground forces and a tank depot second. We storm the airfield make sure no planes fly out of there
Third the helicopter depot, but they'll be after you by then
Last thing remote recon shows a helicopter mission try me out. Yeah, good luck. Love. What's inside destroy it
Think you've got enough to do mech warrior
Think you've got enough to do we've unlocked
Ooziel
The ooziel is a medium mech built to bring impressive firepower
Let's give them a shot if I've unlocked them the new let's see them a wee shot
There are a total of 20 playable missions in microsoft campaign in five
Oh
The
This game cannot balance itself for its freaking life. All right, sorry, there's a wee human here somewhere
Oh
Why okay and then in a mix I'll use the double
Wow
See it's the is these things you really don't want to lose too much damage to the last thing you want
There's so much red on the map
I don't see yeah, okay, that's why I don't want to lose health
I'm trying to play super safe
Because I don't want to
Although we could always try a different make if we if we messed up on a mission. I mean the game really isn't the
I don't think it's too punishing the missions don't actually seem that long until I'd assume that
As if I got hit by
There's something coming off of me
Right we get it
Let's get rid of these bombs
Fucking doing some serious tech damage
Oh, you're gonna think
Okay, this this is why the cougar is probably better or the fumon physics shoot two of these pair one words. I'm just doing one damage now
Mmm, if I picked the wrong bed, I may have but it's okay. I'll try my best
We get it you beat
Oh
Does chat work on screen again for somebody to turn the among us collab chat with not working on screen
I should like literally turn it off and put myself on chat
I'm taking picture
Dude the fuck
The ai is very unforgivable
And they say that like the behind the scenes on video game. Oh my god, it's you you keep making more
Okay, I understand now
Go ape shit on the oh shit. I'm potting fire though
Okay, this is destroying all right it keeps making them sorry
Okay
Good work captain
Hey
So this is like double heat but you have to hit your shot. Is that the only thing okay?
You have to hit your shot. It's the only like the downside or not
Okay, we've got our heels
I don't see any more heels in this area. Hmm
Ha playing this on uji xbox is amazing back in the day
My dad doesn't claim to agree. All right, I can shoot stuff from here. Whoa
Don't let any take off. I'm not even in the vicinity. I I flew too close to the sun
Oh
No, I'm out
Shit
Oh my god
Oh
Oh my god, they're twatting me. I think they're coming back to round two. Oh shit
They are okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I got it. I got it. I got it
Holy shit
Right at least give me a chance. Give me some war
Oh my gosh
Oh my god, I'm taking tech damage. Oh wait, hold on. Take that then
Okay, okay. Okay. They actually didn't have that much health. Uh, right. Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, please mr
Plane don't take off. I'm not ready yet. I'm not in position to destroy you
Wow
Is this more or less of a mech warrior spin-off
Isn't this the original mech?
That's all like any mech type game. I don't know. I'm unsure you you guys would know better than me
Whoa draw bridges to change the position of our draw bridge destroy its control trough tower
Raise bridges will go down and other ones will go up just
This is the control tower
Okay, I'll take it I'll take it. Uh, right we've got some
We've got some boogies ahead
Right so when we pick up that ammo thing basically we just put our weapons like all weapons become a bit more dangerous
Oh, there's a
I put my pants I put my pants
Sorry, I'm I'm hiding in the water
You know, let's cheat and he put them one of those things which means I can't freaking aim out of him
Did he have ulti?
Oh, that's doing some nasty damage like
Oh
Fuck that could the ultimate down. Oh it did. I don't know what button that did
Oh, he's gone. He is gone
Oh, you've destroyed the bridge. Oh, no the mr. Friar truck. No
Oh, oh, he was just he was just trying to collect his paycheck and pay his mortgage
Oh
Oh, poor little mr. Friar truck. I'm sorry. That was a man tension
Now someone has to go to make explain to his wife and kids why daddy's no coming home
Oh
Yeah, I was gonna see the collateral like in warfare is it absolutely insane number
No, what now what he doesn't have to pay his mortgage. No. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I did him a favor actually
See you're worrying about
Uh
Look on the bright side capitalism could no longer exploit him. No
But now it's like
Whoa, oh, I thought it's gonna get away with that without it. Yeah
Oh, wait, no, you guys are like super weak. I don't need to do the big one on them
Okay, it's like two shots on a chopper is that whoa, there's one above me
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Don't think you're getting away. You should be once you're done for
I hope it was worth it. Fuck you
Exactly god. I'm getting low health
Wait, why am I I'm drowning?
Uh, you can drown in this game question mark. This is news to me
Look how much damage I just took because I was sitting in the water. Are you joking me?
And there's a fucking mech on this way
Oh my god, too deep in the water starts flooding the fucking mech
Oh one enemy ahead of me
Is it gonna come over so I can shoot him? I just took so much damage. I don't have to use
Where's the enemy?
Wait the chopper is the fucking enemy
I was a bit overkill
Oh my god, I need health but I don't have it
No, no that one
I need the auto aim. Oh, I don't like this
Oh, there's gonna be a mix I and I'm gonna get rules because I'm fucking half health because I
I'm trying please don't spawn in any mix. Please. I'm begging
Okay
You meddle in that what you do not understand
I don't have heels wait no no no no no no no no no no no no no
Hold on hold on hold on. Let me win. Let me win. Please. I'm on my knees. Please
I didn't realize I didn't real oh fuck. I completely missed that one off. Oh my god. Please get the limping one first
It's better to take out oh shit that increases my heels my
Overcharge hold on. Hi. Is there gonna have heels over here on the second map?
No, oh, that's okay. I guess I didn't need it. Right. They both put their prima facia. Oh
My god, I'm actually gonna leave them
Cuz I freaking stood in war
No, he's not dead. Oh, he'll fail break the building break them
Okay, okay, okay, okay take out the weaker one first, okay, that's what we like to see
All right, and then take him out. Nope, he's completely messed up. Oh my god, these fucking helicopter pads are fucking saying that they're
Right, okay, okay, I think we're okay. I don't want to I think
Okay, that's what I want to see, baby
Oh
Can you back up I do not want you to explode in my face
No, everything see these helicopter pads. Oh my god, they're registering as like something that's in my way
Oh
Oh my god, she said honestly slayed you were lucky that the
Strategically left mek hearing I am forever and hmm. Yeah
The dialogue in this game is like a
Oh
Captain our objective has always been to disrupt the word of Blake and disable the orbital guns
I cannot believe I almost lost the top about right weren't you just telling me that last night cowboy
Sirs the job is this
Are the commentators, you know make it out to see working each other for the orbital guns
So this is critical. The problem is going to be the terrain
Hold on a minute. I'm just gonna slow you down. So keep an eye out for shortcuts over dry land
What madman would ask Johnny Keese that make
Get to it mek warrior time to get wet. Yo, we don't need to know you're like
Whoa
Lial
Billy L a variant of the Ozil is built to field up here or formidable
Gossas rifle and I never use rifles, you know that I
Don't I don't think I don't think he's the one I
Don't think he's the one
Now is he'll against a mech is like pretty OP. I'm quite I'm quite biased to zeal right now
He is not the one pronounced like
I
Have no idea what mission
So I looked up and they were like this game takes the average to play but I'm like
I think it I don't think it takes eight hours. I'm not under the impression. It actually is the ever matter to show
Don't have to tell me twice. Fuck it up. Fuck it up. Fuck it up. Oh, you've got a whole breach
Oh, no, you're taking water on board. Oh, no, I don't get your life jacket on
Oh, it's too late. No, there's not enough time for the life jacket
Eight game journalist hours, okay, maybe eight for a hundred percent. I don't I don't think there's any hundred percent
There's no like collected or anything
Oh
That's creative putting a freaking turret on a bridge, I did not expect that you know what video game
Yeah, that's what I thought honestly, but do that again
Don't even make me regret being so nice
I'm missing on purpose
Oh, I've done it. That's I just pretty satisfying when it's one shot. It feels like this is a shotgun in terms of late
Oh
Wow, I'm just destroying the entire river
Sometimes
Whoa, sorry the controls are a bit funny. Please remember this game is back when
Whoa, what was that?
Oh, thank God back in the day when they were like made things invisible they weren't actually invisible so they were like being nice to you
I
Remember playing a similar mech assault game, but on the Xbox you're gonna shit yourself when you find out this next piece of information
This is mech assault from the Xbox original
Very good game
My it's probably one of the first games I was a child
Just when it comes to
Stuff
Can you play that? Yeah, I feel like a
Who's gonna love you
Destroy the drawbridge
Now the townspeople can escape you're welcome
Go home are you parish? Do I meet?
Oh
Did I feel oh, sorry, I was person about sorry lads may just feel this mission cuz I've been having a Katie on
Hurry up, I'm sorry. I was freaking role-playing. Okay. I was letting the townspeople escape
You need to play with that beggar. I don't know how those
Obviously like back in the day. Yeah, those controllers thought
I
Don't like that
Big big coming I see big big on the map
Nope, that was just a tiny human
You are not giving me a chance
Sorry, I did not
He's stuck if he's stuck I'm leaving. I'm sorry if the if the game might
You didn't even give me a fucking second you didn't even give me a fucking second even I
Pissed the ball. I pissed about for like 50%. Oh, yeah. Oh, sorry. My wee Xbox is good
It's got dust in the fans. Sorry. My Xbox has dust in the fans. If you saw that my apologies
I messed around and that we towned for how long I
Literally destroyed am I going crazy. I destroyed a drawbridge and then that was it I was done
Bro these games are brutal
I
Ain't exactly making much
Just focus on the river every second you stop to do anything the boat. Yeah, literally timed mission. Hey
Honestly, is it all getting done for it? I don't know why video games
At least I know was coming up ahead so I can kind of deal with it as a
as
I
That's not what that meant in French. I meant as I arrive
That means something else in French. It means fireworks in French
So I do apologize the one French person listening in right now my bad. She's sorry
Right don't stop
Moving down the river
Ten shots, please do not pair a friend
Well, he's limping
Wow
He'll point
We're just gonna have to keep her going
Keep her going that make one some of this you can come get it
Let's get some I
Hate timed missions. They always suck. Thank you. I'm glad you guys freaking agree
I don't know why they insist on them. I hate a cheeky time mission
Like even in Assassin's Creed Brotherhood, they have like those missions where you have to like
Hold on, let me get my game
I'm getting a bit more. I'm not gonna lie. I'm getting a wee bit more than I'd like
Wait, this is the end of the math if I go in the wrong way. No, I couldn't have the boy
I'm trying to chase a ship. I'm trying my best. I really am
I'm ready to spank something that comes in my peripheral have I gone the wrong way
Because I'm about to start getting the ships we're getting away
And then the cutscene is like every like five seconds like oh, thanks. Yeah, I really caught up to that ship. He got me
Oh
Sorry, I think I'm gonna have to pick up the tail. I really am
Okay, let's get a fucking move one. I need to tell sorry I do
Here we go here we go here we go
Oh
That's what I missed. Okay. Okay. Oh
That makes much more sense. I was like, where the heck are they going?
Disappearing on me like that. I love the air
I remember when you need to kill three war generals in
Five minutes in a feature
Infidel brethren watch and learn
You
Here's our situation
We're landing in what we hope is a secure location, but it looks like the enemy may have spotted us
There's several enemy units in the area and
Towards our position as soon as we learn you'll need to secure the landing zone
More interesting. It looks like the word is transporting a new mad cat
We need more firepower. So I want that heavy mech
It's against my better judgment, but once you capture the mad cat lieutenant Foster will pilot it back to the Icarus
Try and make sure that breathing boy doesn't kill himself
Right, I'm I'm sorry, but Ooziel is kind of getting me good. I have to admit that double
and
That double
Will be on the ground momentarily
Destroying mech so quickly. I'm very biased
Double PPC. Hmm. Defend it
They know what help they ain't gonna know what help give me
Hey
Is this their soul is he gonna come through the trees?
No, he's actually using hold on a minute. He's using
Whoa, you take four heads. Well, maybe I should have gone quicker because he
Wait, why this doesn't do any heat damage
No, no, no, no, no, no, I'm the only
I'm the only one that's supposed to do this. I make myself clear
Wait, okay, hold on hold on and then one more. No
Shit, I'm over here
No
Okay
I don't know how much health this thing has
Oh
They really require for god this game got me stressed. This is a I thought gaming was supposed to be freaking
What role am I playing the victim?
There's one over to the right. I can see on the HUD and he's fucking getting take damage and fuck you you little shit
Oh my god, it's like literally on fire
Oh my god, stop
Stop, I think I'm actually gonna lose the section
No more I can't take anymore. Oh, thank god
Okay, oh my god
Reflings are either baddies. No, we're rebel. Wait, are we the baddies in this game? I was like, we're really goodies
Right, I'm staying out the water until I know it's not too
That makes go so much colder than the rocket's permanently negative. So that ppc
Well, that's why I like camping in the water
But as I learned from that other round, right, there's an enemy there, but I don't even think you can
He does an awful lot of what's in you in the works
Is this I have gone the wrong way, please forgive my ignorant
We are the neutral third party that the locals picked to fight with
If if if the lower class picks us then surely we're the goodies
Sure
That's how it works, right
I love the tanks taking like a bit of side damage there. That was kind of funny like it almost flipped on its side a little bit
The aim control goes different when you're like inside that week two days
Hey, you ain't getting me
Something here that is getting me though
What is that just uh
Just a wee tank off you pop off you pop see and you know my problem anymore off you pop
Whoa, whoa. Oh, I'm trying to reach out. Give me a freaking say. I see a health though
I'll take it. I'll take it. I see health. Oh sugar that went right on me
Now's not the time in film trade now's not the time
Ah
Okay, I need to cool down
I'm gonna
At least you're gonna have health on this
Fuck you. Oh my god. Oh get away. Get away. Did anyone take damage?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm over here
Just trying to commit to war crimes against but you can't say that stuff at live
I read that out loud my youtube channel gets shut down instantly
Oh, whoa, I was not paying attention
Yeah, fuck them trees up. Yeah, fuck them up
I
Am I overheating hold on
Uh, give me just give me a saying they'll come kill you and saying just my mix. Uh, it's gonna be a bit warm
We bet we bet to stay inside this mix
No
Stop them and foster and our techs will take care of it. Okay a tamed convoy a tamed convoy
Don't get too distracted. There's a tamed convoy
I can handle the convoy
Okay
I'm trying
I'm
I
All right, fuck this
Am I gonna lose it? I think I am
Because the convoy keeps moving stop moving
Stop moving I'm fucking the convoy. I'm fucking the med cat
I know I'm
Me and the boys in the in the mad cat oh something's gonna happen
Oh, is that supposed to be him picking up the mech
On your position
Okay, okay, I can do that
I'm so brave. I'm brave. Can you get the fuck out of my way? Oh crap. Where are they coming from?
Oh
Like the simulator I need some time
I'm sorry, mate. No, I can't even aim right. You're so small. I can't even hit you
Oh, shoot
The mechs are coming from this way the mechs are coming from this way serpentine serpentine
I don't know why I thought they would come the other way. This seems they were coming from behind
Wow
Reinforcement
Okay
I thought it was gonna be what wait, he's not even gonna help me fight bro turn around you have fucking artillery anything
Oh
Ah, hold on I need to learn
Come on and I walked right into that hold on this could be a health pack
Yeah, you're getting done. Yeah, you're getting done. No, okay after I told that building you're done for
Did I make myself clear?
Oh, come on
Bro, you must perish. Yeah. Yeah, you don't fire
Okay, I need to like date him back
I hope he's okay
I'm clear of the city. I'm hearing me Icarus. Good work, lieutenant foster
Captain for good measure destroy the base at the north end of the city and don't leave any of those buildings standing
Uh, total annihilation. Yes, ma'am
You don't have to tell me why I said no power for you
No power. No one's allowed electricity
I'm saving you allergy because how can they charge electricity if it'll provide you the service seat? You're welcome
I don't want to waste the purple
Fuck you
Oh, this is satisfying. Oh, I wouldn't take it that one over there
Hold on hold on give me a second. Let him get up
Wow, okay, I have to admit sniping from afar. I'm I'm here for it. Oh, wow
I just need that broken to go up
Stop spawning in your unit
Stop it. Please do not go on that helicopter
Okay
Okay, we've done the helicopter one now we're going to do the car one
Okay, and then there's something over there. I can see me
Okay
I have to admit leveling an entire area very satisfying
Oh, no, they're gonna be mixed behind something because look there's a health pack there and there
Wait, something's shooting at me. A car? How dare you?
Wait, I can't auto look. I was gonna say I'm pretty sure I can auto look
I'm trying
I just take a little whale. Okay. I can I think the boss battle. I'm gonna be honest. I said I'm sorry
It's starting to get a feeling there's gonna be a boss battle. Well, that level up meat. I go back
Uh, can I destroy this by walking into it?
I'm getting nervous
Good work
But I call dibs oh man, I love this
Now this is the dom content from a complete flattening babies for him time for you days
Whoa, I've got signatures heading towards us. Well, we didn't even you have a cutscene or nothing
right
Mind yourself lieutenant piloting a mech is not a game
Wait, am I supposed to be lieutenant right now? Whoa, my cat has four auto logs. I'm here for it
Um overheating though, this is a heavy mecha. Oh look, there's me wait
The dialogue is like so cute
Oh
Bro, you're kind of cramping my sail with your aim
Wow, it takes a while to load that for a math admit that's like it's not instant. It's like a
Reload
Oh my god, but this is so I'm doing like so much damage that things aren't like alive long enough to even hurt me
I'm looking at what the AI is trying to do something's sponding because look I'm going for it. He's even
Where is it? Where's it? Oh this guy can't fly
Is that take reduced damage
I think that may be reduced damage
Lieutenant has been given your make now you're having the magical
Ah
Heavy makes can't fly too big. Okay. I like that detail. I assume my little
Is there something out here about me?
I think something's stuck. Oh, here we go
Can't see the fight for the trees
Oh
That's got hurt. Yeah, we what six maybe six
Oh, I missed because of the tree have you
Oh, no, I'm still eight
I mean, that was too less
So still definitely heavy cat. I'm a fan of a heavy make
It won't be more another one. There's choppers inbound
more like choppers out of
Order instead of inbound
Go that one
I can see that there's a mech approaching
Oh, did I get you? I did not get you. What did get you? Hold on. Let me deal with the mech or something
All right, you next and then you
All right, let's take the aggro off of the fucking
I that missed again. Okay. Wow purple is like putting them on glass
Wow
For hit for oh my god, that was so good
Oh, yeah, good job briefing boy. Okay. I'm a bit of a simp for the mad cat right now. That was a this is a good make
Okay, we've got the word of Blake's attention. So now we hurt them
One of their key tactical command centers is a nick of everything. We're ever gonna have a chance to get those global guns
We've got to take it out. We can't hit them head-on. So we're gonna turn out the lights
I like is so large. It has to try to attack
We're gonna blow that plant and I take ten beech ever make a soul and I don't think anything came up of the original
And I'm like, oh, am I making reach of her history the only mech?
We've got powerful enough to handle this is the magic
Don't make me making each of your history the first person to make a soul. Oh, you don't have to ask me twice. Oh
Um, you're a unique gamer. Yeah
Okay, first official mission is the mad cat bright lights dark sea
It's a lot for battle tech rare for beachable is that touch battle tech game?
Um, doesn't Titanfall 2 count as a battle tech?
Right, hold on
I'll write that down somewhere
Thanks
Yeah, literally bro, as I said these games do not follow the etiquette when it's in the tree to fall in
You're supposed to like be given like five seconds. Whoa
You're supposed to be given some abbreviation to the enemies like shooting at yeah, this game does not give life to the rats
Oh, wow, it splits up the aim as well. So, okay, that's really good if it splits up the aim
It's technically like less to do
Right mad cats can't fly must remember mad cats cannot fly because I'm gonna get confused when I'm in the middle of my fight
And I'm like get up get up get up
And nothing's happening
Okay, there we go
There seems to be two enemies over here
One
Yeah, I can kind of see why they had to put AI. Oh, I just picked up sorry
Sorry, you were just on transport
Bridges whoa
Uh the bridge
What's going on am I going mental I'm getting absolutely kablami
Is there stuff constantly respawned
There's one of them respawned buildings back there. I don't I can't identify the title
Sir twin pumas outbound from the base
Uh get me in the water in the water. I love being in the water
Water to be in the water right now
Oh, I'm not really cooling down that much
Mmm
Get away from me. He's gonna explode. Oh shit. I'm at events of the game. I'm not supposed to go any further back
Bruh pull up
Is it gonna drop right behind me now
Sorry bro
Okay, we're okay. We're okay as long as we don't
First
Oh, we're fucking him. Oh one more. Yeah, he's limping
I always wanted a city of bio
Right, we need to blow up the bridge
Is it faster?
To my fans already made that joke go away already made that joke. I think the water strat is best for the rocket
Oh
And not this one
Bridges dusted well done. That'll keep the base from sending out help. Can I hit from here?
Oh, I can't
You
You and we're done
Whoa god my poor xbox. It's so old. That's really struggling
I'm glad that it can capture the game
Yes, I'm glad my xbox original survived
Do you guys remember when xbox crystal was a thing?
Hmm just remember that are you too much of a baby?
Because I oh wait, I can press a to fire not trigger. Oh
Wait for real that Titanfall 3
Wait, you're playing on xbox. Yeah, I'm on the xbox original. It's working so well right now
I don't know how an air
It's doing so well after being in storage for over 20 years
Oh my god, that's
The tunnel this tunnel right here
Oh, who are you even got any arms?
Well, I think you like you
Mate sit down
I'm getting
I'm getting my boss wall up tear hold on not the good kind
The sore kind the kind that no one wants
Okay, we've got it
No
The bridge the bridge is in the way of my target
Oh, we've got it. We've got it and one more which is dead ahead
Did you ever dust the maybe was messing up with transition? Yeah
Yeah, great great good advice. Thank you
Guys, this isn't emulator. That's why it's fucking up
Wait, I'm gonna go here. Okay time for the newt plant itself
Foster set up the tactical data. Yes, sir. The OGA flow control is like a hundred bucks raw. Oh
Ah wait no part two what it's loading a new area. It's still the same map. Okay, sir
The newt plant is inside a contained area to get through the gate
You need to destroy the power generator
Take out defenders around generator. Okay defender
Take out defenders there's something in front of you
I freaking saw yous on the HUD. He's such me liars honestly
I saw you appear on the HUD before me
Oh, no, I'm overheating
Wow two for one, baby
Right destroy defenders first. So it's okay that I'm
I'm alive
These trees are taking an absolute ham. Whoa, whoa, please don't break the game
Please don't break. Please don't break
Please don't break. I really don't want to lose progress
I would actually be really sad if we had to restart
Whoa, there's a mech on the field
Oh
I'm too high temperature. I did say take out defenders as long as it's not tamed mission. We can push us about as much as we could
I get him. I want that mech. I want that mech out of the sky
I want him out of the sky
Uh, he looks like he's taking damage
Stop it, bro. You're killing me. You're supposed to let me win
Video game devs. What are you doing? You're supposed to let the cards win
Oh
Okay, there we go. I'll take that. That'll do me just standing right new chopper
Uh, right, let's see in the cars
Bang
Okay, this is the base up ahead
Sorry
This is creating bases. Yeah
Wait, stop the base the base that's making them destroy the base that's making them not the thing over and over and over again
Hold on. There's something coming up. So
Did I break it? I did
Whoa
Not the tree's feeling like literally the best thing ever
Hold on
Okay, here we go. Here we go
Well, there's one behind me. Hold on. I need like to try
Oh, come on. Break already. Break
Okay, that's all I want to see
Oh, we're in a bit of a oh no, not that not that. Not that. This, this, this. Yes
I'm well in the hill on the hill
Oh, we're almost done. We're almost done. We're almost done. We're almost done. safe safe safe safe safe safe safe
Okay
We will cool down
We will cool down. We will look for some health. There should be something
you're supposed to let the player win for himself begs to differ brah I would
not be anywhere I am without you guys carrying me that lion I cannot I spoke
just send a little bit after and I watch her play it and I'm like brah you guys
have like such good patience it's insane like I did not have the patience to be
like I don't know like I mean I know it's like oh get good scrolls like I
don't you guys have fantastic patience like it's such a good trait to be able to
do that like you're honestly I don't ironically like that patience that you
can show by like playing it and like trying to beat it and that perseverance
is like fantastic
that's why I didn't want to overheat then you would have freaking company right
oh there's a healing stick oh there's also stuff inside that warehouse I can
see it I have to actually use the road like a normal net for from
soft really does not care if you beat it or not I thought yeah that is not our
problem it says it's pointing this way like to go back it's a lot easier to be
patient for something you know in advance will take a long time and not be
stuck on something that you think should be easy I guess yeah like if you know
what you're getting into she just spent like six hours beating vanilla whoa a
couple of days ago yeah I believe it like I I don't have the patience that I
suck I just be like I want to continue I'm gonna pick up a few items she says
that she like never does any I am crafting all
people hands if I do this
ha ha limping already oh suck it getting up boosted upgrade is so good like
absolutely suck it bro I don't know I think it's normal to keep going until
you win that's just a termination
oh just in case you were wondering this is a nuclear fusion plant so when you
destroy it you won't glow in the dark true but I still wouldn't want to be near
when it blows any nuclear fusion fanboys
wait hold on on my bill it can't hit you
where where I don't see something should be from behind infantry you stop that
oh here he comes here he comes hold on let's see let's try it let's try it we
have we have hold on hold on take your time no rush no rush oh the fucking
damage up get fucked oh come on he's like one HP in a dream okay yeah hold on
let me recover let me recover some of that me energy come on come on no how is
that an evade and what country was that an invade evade hold on oh is he stuck
I think you make it stop I mean sure I'll just leave you out here buddy don't
mind if I do oh he's still not perished whoa another man
wow okay this is our first three battle mix right wait there's another one hold
on is this a mech plant I think it's a mech plant it's a mech plant I think we're
gonna have to destroy it like that pick up his help and then we're just gonna go
for it because if they're just gonna keep respawning mix there's no point in
trying to hold back he's stuck help he's stuck step man oh my god robot
confirmed for gen 2 that gets stuck all the time
oh there's another one okay yeah whoa no no no no no no come on come on how much
come on fuck me I'm actually getting a bloat
I'm getting absolutely snaked out the wazoo yeah yeah I make default I'm shocked
I'm surprised I really amic people I wouldn't have I would never have yet
at all I would never have yet that's all I need to destroy a mix of life holy crap
holy crap please perish like you pick up your health I'm actually get perished
holy holem moley holem moley I'm gonna make it in time holem moley okay but
tell yes I know there's a make default holy crap dad dad come fucking help me
in this game holy crap I saw right make default destroy make default destroy
make people destroy make people yeah I'm fucking up so badly right now I'm not
gonna lie not they've already spawned in the next two fuck me oh why is my dad so
good at this game hold on I need to do this I think I might need to I think I
might need to take the L on the damage and come back to I keep getting pushed
off I'm getting pushed off no way I'm down I'm down my health is too little
fully crap you need to I need to like perish this guy like right now I need
his health we did get a lick on the building that's the good news okay okay
okay take your time take the health that comes off of him I can do that okay
double the hell are you not the default are you not the default
okay there's a health station to the left of the people I can see it I'm sorry
this needs to go down I killed myself on the fusion reactor I killed myself on
the fusion reactor no I freaking okay I let me keep my my thing I killed myself
on the fusion okay at least I know if I just bomb rush it and go to a little to
be confused with okay okay okay trash the generator yep yep yep yep yep yep
it's okay it's okay right I need to go straight for it yeah okay I forgot about
those guys I'm gonna be honest I actually forgot okay I do like the match
abilities but the overheat penalty is rough like it is rough they definitely
balance my cat oh my god walks into a nuclear power plant oh my gosh how could
I be so dumb oh my god there's makes around here I forgot oh my god it's all
falling apart so fallen apart I'm being so dumb now I need to start using my
ultimate more I don't know if it means more damage or less more more defense I
can constantly hear that right don't go on a wall again I need your HP Wow
actually you know how that guy got caught in that wall I'm wondering if I
should try and get caught in a wall again so then I've only got one guy to
oh my goodness gravy right next is the depot or cars
hold on
come on
destroy it with one more spawn and one more good you're next and you're next and
you're next God give me a second to free right do these get crushed a little
bit let us recuperate and get what we need and in terms of a page me there must
be something in the city I know there was something in the bunker yeah okay
there was something in the bunker was there some health there's a heel to the
lift I will absolutely take that thank that's it that's all it heals oh no not
we can stop right I am solo health sorry there's no healing of value oh there
here okay okay at least we know what to do oh my god the health hardly gives you
anything oh if I lose this we're gonna make a cup of tea and come back you have
to have faith in me shit is he coming to work no he's not I'm a bones for him
no he's coming I've used my ultimate I've been a good girl I would very much
like your help right now I said I'd very much like your health right now okay we
much for that that's fantastic okay that's better now there are two little
shooty mix shooters out here yeah yeah I got a bullet raid by the fusion plant
the game literally tells you don't don't mess it up and what's the first thing I
go do yeah okay I can't fly I can't fly so I just have to go for it and I'm
already freaking through I can't come back for health if I need it but the
problem is my cat's penalty is so large yes yeah I'm already up to my ears
right now bro oh I'm not gonna lie I'm not sure this is the best thing I've
heard fuck it I think we're gonna go all in all in on the make people and then
we'll destroy the health station that's to my left okay it's fucking over for
you to it was nice playing with you but it's over it's actually over sorry it's
actually over for you you suck hold on let me be in the water
hidden health okay there's health and health people and make people come on
get one first so at least let me pick up the health and then I'm gonna back the
away from this maybe it's mud no more I'm gonna back right off I'm not going I'm
not being near this thing when I knew get
surely this is enough range or distance
well okay we did it we did it we just have to go again it's fine
I'm just going to take a look at this wait the game's just thrown me into the
next mission it's not even like it's not even like shove me under it's snowing
we're in Scotland what what they even put enough detail on the snow you've
hot dropped we thought dropped you out of the winded Icarus locate it and
protect it go make a tea thank God she shot a mom like I mean yeah yeah yeah
swift and quick we get it okay I'm gonna very quickly make a wee cup of tea
in verne Bonnie in verne final um how many missions are we in sorry if you can
hear my PC die and turn to emulator sorry I mean how many motion I just rolled
over my microphone I hope you're okay little microphone they're there oh okay
maybe we can make you know fuck it fuck it we'll just lock in we'll lock in I
don't know how far through we are if it's gonna break the emulator no the real
then yeah sorry I'm not gonna risk it I don't know why it was doing that for
some reason playing it the frame rate I can't handle the snow what now the Xbox
design yeah the dust particles in it are really a really given me a hard time
right now oh you pesky dust part dust particles are in between the motherboard
of this little thing oh you all shots
I pulled out here already
oh my god the frame rate is worse than before I give us like 26 at 24 is the
normal resting frame rate
I'm gonna need this map oh wait I'm taking health damage walking into those buildings
no not a map right now I'm still freaking garbage hold on hold on hold on hold on
no no this can't be come on I just want a cup of tea man I just want to eat
cup of tea okay next time it says for next mission we'll do the cup of tea hold
on oh come on and land already
that was a direct hit by the machine one oh
we got our health whoa we got some of her health like that actually wasn't all
the health oh take the disc out and blow on it okay
oh I could lure that right don't walk into buildings actually what a unique map
I actually don't recall this map much so I assume my dad didn't like it because he
only replied missions that he liked and I don't recognize this one so it must be a
bad one question mark I see that make to my left yeah oh come on I'm constantly
overheating we're on snow we're on snow why is the mech not even freezing over
do you to mind seriously do you to mind okay I'm in the middle of a fight here
is the legit Microsoft development kit yeah exactly my dad works at Microsoft
I'm getting a blamled by the turrets the little amount of damage they do adds up
quickly though to the point you can get trouble no one wants to be in charge
sir can you read us yes captain we are in decent shape yeah
the word troops don't know that and are holding back for now I'm coming I'm coming
oh there's not a time mission oh my god if I could stop overheating for one second
then I'm gonna go to sleep tonight and all I'm gonna hear is like the
overheat noise hold on let's bring that bar down sure your dad works a
microtop yeah no totally he's like best puzzle Bill Gates and everything oh he
was oh he was on the death team silly me oh yeah well something's coming you
are they gonna evade it no he's gonna walk right into it I'm not gonna say no
to that are you joking he's limping already I'm not gonna say no to that if
you want to walk into my shot sure not to yourself buddy
I am I'm happy that I was a result and a half okay
is that gonna finish him off it's nice he's like overheating I don't want him to
explode over my head though because they do insane damage have you really lived
until the warning signs infiltrate your mind for me it's ace combat missile
alert an altitude warning I think there was like this weird remix song made
about Starcraft and it was like evac our forces are under attack and that's the
best I've got whoa yeah there's so much on the ground right now I do not trust
this holy crap look at how much is on the ground oh my gosh no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no nonor answers
because I'm gonna need it I'm gonna clearly eighty oh no
Oh, no
Just one okay, that's one
Get me in the water or the ace I guess get me in the ice
Okay, I'm gonna pick up one health. Oh, I hardly did anything
Oh, no, this can't be
I
Was we arms falling off
Yeah, I can tell there's more enemies look how much stuff you've given me
There's a mad cat. No, I'm the only mad cat
He's supposed to be in front of me. Hello
You're not in front of me. You're above me
You're stinky
Can I get one hit, please? Just so I'm not completely wasting everything
Okay
Okay, I need to take out the weird guy first
I'm sweating I'm sweating and not the good thing I
Won't be laughing until my butt cheeks are dry. That's so hard. I'm sweating right now. Holy crap
I'm not laughing. No one's cheating in right now
No complete mess
What was the frickin bar? Please don't hit me. Please don't hit me. No
I'm meeting today. I love I'm stuck. I thought I swear there was something around here. Oh
My god, give me the rocket upgrade. I'll take it. I'll take it. Okay. He's limping. He's limping. He's limping. Okay
Okay, okay
Okay, we did it. We did it
Oh, cup of tea time
Okay, I'm gonna
Hide the game off the screen just in case it starts flashing again because I don't want any epileptic seizure experience for folksic
Can you see me blinking that's because the screen is going absolutely ape shit right now
Right, I'm gonna very quickly make a cup of tea. Sorry. Let me take off reactive model. There we go
I'm currently getting flashbang right now. I'll be right back. I'll make a click of tea very quickly
Please get all a wee snackie poo or anything of that nature. Okay?
You
Are you squiddin me right now
I may or may not have put cat food in my tea
Oh
Here's the score the Icarus sitting duck we need to set up another base so we can finish the job and take out those orbital
Towers the enemy and I just made my tea there, and I'm like I can read from our own sense
So I'm about to figure out
Thor on the rocks are we already on Ragnarok are we getting close?
Sorry, did someone say oh, thank you. Don't stay down for the
Super chat
Bro, I just the Oreo just all in my bed extra protein. I mean
Uh, cat food isn't fit for human consumption, which I don't like
I'd rather
Oh
How many missions Thor on the rocks are being in close? I'm getting nervous
Timberwolf, who are you a variant of the successful mat the timber wolf has suited for any
battlefield role
I don't
I don't use the pew-pews, but I use the shoulder thing below. Is this eight shoulder things?
They're faster though
Timberwolf right fuck it. We'll give Timberwolf a go. Yeah Timberwolf. Let's go
Make sure wonder what they put in the cat food. Yeah
I'll fucking out just fondant
Forgot how it play like in five seconds. Um, oh it comes to snow
Uh
Yeah, do you if you want to hear how dumb I was as a child are they gonna come from the top? Oh, yeah, they are
Oh, no, they only have super um
They are
um
So this is probably the most disgusting story you're gonna hear all day
Um, I used to eat cat food when I was like four years old because I was convinced it would turn me into a cat
um
So I could have a very vivid memory of uh under the kitchen sinkers where the cat food who was uh like in her house
And I used to take a spoon fill out of the tin and eat it because I thought it was gonna turn me into a cat
And yeah, it's not my brightest moment
Uh
I don't know why in my head it was gonna turn me into a cat. It just was like, yeah, that makes perfect sense if I eat this cat food
So I I know what cat food tastes like
Uh, I could tell by the smell if a cat's gonna enjoy it or not because of this dumb thing I did as a freaking child
Um, but it's like I can laugh at it now, but oh my god
Yeah
My my shock and horror that I just wake up with cat ears
I
And it and that behavior went on for quite a while. I'm not even gonna lie. I think it was probably a solid month
I would just wonder the cupboard a bit. Oh, I need a little snack
And if my mom didn't give me a snack, I just wonder
And the thing is all cat food labels like have a thing on it
That's like not fit for human consumption because of like the guts that they usually like
Oh
And the worst thing is it's not like it was refrigerated like it was open
Oh, hold on. Sorry
Sorry video game. I'm telling this really disgusting story. The worst part was it wasn't refrigerated. It's like open canned
a
Like cat food
How old were you at the time four? I was like four not 13. Stay on
What if I told you you're not the first person to tell a story like this? Oh, thank god
I
Feel a bit better now then if that's the case
Was it wet? Yeah, it was like the wet jelly in the can
I still remember the noise the spoon made as I took it out of the can like that
Um, it's absolutely mean. I know I'm so sorry. I don't have any excuse
But that's hilarious that someone else told me
I don't know. It just makes perfect sense. Like of course cat food people as if that just kamikaze into that
I can't see this chopper. He's out of range. But he is there are there is
You're next buddy
Find and destroy the wobb sense or net
Wait, so I need to go back again
I get eaten kivel, but jeez. Yeah, like that's why
So I'm a bit passionate. I'm like, no, I don't want uh
I'd rather cat food said it's fit for human consumption. Not because I want to eat it
And turn into a cat. But because
I don't think that you should be giving your pet something that you the human aren't fit to consume
um
Lack of nutrients for humans, but it's generally safe in an emergency the furry arc. No, I'll pass
AC's like
in development
AC was like as far as we'll go
Right
Um, because we did entertain the possibility
But we decided it would be far too much of a
I can see so much red, but it's not like giving me one thing to shoot at
Um, but we decided it was far too much of a like negative thing. Holy crap. Something is like obliterating me
You you're obliterating
Right, I'm going the wrong way. Hold on. I guess we have to come back that way. Gee, there's like so many countries though
I think there's one in the rocks, maybe
Anyway long story short, I'm a special child. Is there one hiding? I'm so confused. It says there's something there
There's an enemy back out there
You can spam with a wildcat though. What is get you? Yep. I knew you were right there. I can see you on the hot
Well, what are you?
Okay, so this is the mad cat egg
Whoa, something's getting me from behind as well. Holy shit. You pop off
I hate when the game does that when these bombs aren't behind you because look how long it takes to freaking do a 180
I'm half out as well. I don't like that at all
Oh my god, please perish. What's going on?
Wow, don't do that again
Holy moly, you almost got me. Something up here? Com tower?
What's this then?
Whoa
Oh, it's cool. She's our special boomer on the floor
When it was a child, I played with stuffed animals until they just have an even two in the school and they need honey
And donate them all to cousin. That's what I'm holding. Oh, that's fucking sad as fuck though
I remember my time. I got she got stolen at school
I was raging because I knew exactly who did it and then the next year the freaking
B-Och came back to school with it a year later
And she's like, oh, I ran out of battery and I'm like, yeah, could you stole it off me and it's been a year you fucking
bought
Um
How is the cat tea by the way? Okay before I forget but before the game starts like flashing us
Hold on. I'm just gonna run in circles so the game doesn't like flash
I don't know why stuffing makes it like panic
Did I beat her up? I was like six years old. I did not beat her up. Um
I basically I
Knew she stole it. I told the teacher but the teacher like obviously didn't have the right to pat down a child or check through their bag
um
And basically the teacher was like, yes, Ronnie. Sorry, but you shouldn't have like you shouldn't bring
Stuff into school that you can lose type idea. Hold on. I'm drinking my tea. I can't I don't I don't sense any cat
Uh cat like um dusting
In it
If I read slime girl one more day, I see slime girl more than purple burglar alarm at this point
Name air name air asking for slime girl. That's everyone's getting bent over anyone that types slime girl's getting bent over
And I'm absolutely taking a bollican
Because I've had enough
I'm putting my foot down the scottish vtuber gets asked for a fucking slime girl more than bloody purple burglar alarm
Which everyone's obsessed by asking scottish people about
Don't tempt them honestly
A slime boy remember that time I was entertaining a male branch and then it like completely dissolved overnight
I have no interest now
Oh
Yeah, but what about you know, slime
Can you see squirrel eye? It's the french that can you see squirrel they go squee well
Who a little squee well
Just kidding a squee well
Someone needs to make a compilation of every time someone asks about slime girl, bro
They'd be at it for months
You'd get more content out of people asking me for a slime girl than I do burps in general
Yeah, french people go squee well wait, how did you say it's girl?
Why a squirrel oh like there goes a squirrel
Sounds like a short side deal actually I need to make a short. What was it?
Oh fine. I guess you add my wee pog champ. Yeah, it was like something like that
I need to make that I also need to make a song cover. So honestly if this game if we
Do the opposite of game journalists this game that actually might come in fantastic and I can get even more work done
I I my goal is to get a 2k. Thank you audio out
Am
Though I'm going to do the ear cleaning one because it has a funny little joke at the start. I think that one's the best
I'm sorry. I keeping this dream buried for now slowly stewing in fermentin
Look if one of the girls say they want a halloween slime variation
Fine, okay. It's a whole new model. It's a whole new artwork. It's a whole new design fine. They can have it
But no one is asked for one
Game journalists or game regroup just a short shawnee shaming us for ideas. No, I don't I'm not shaming
but like there's some stuff that's like
If you don't know you don't know and like one of the unwritten rules are
You know like don't have a cyclops. It's offputting people don't like it as a design debuff
and
You know someone being green again design debuff unless you made them only a tinge of green and said they were a halfling
But she's like a muscle mummy in comparison to the average human sure fine. Let it happen multiple eyes
Insect these are kind of unwritten things that are against the the norms and I'm happy to talk about it
But I get nervous when I talk about it people take it like oh, she said insect girls
Bad that means she hates and it's like no motherfucker. That's not how design works. You have to appeal to the masses
The masses and you need to give a model to someone that isn't a debuff
That isn't something that makes it even harder for them to succeed as a feature creator
hey
Oh, the shadows are back in full force. I'm slamming the desk. That's when you know, I was hardly slamming it
I gave it a little bump
Yeah, yeah slam sly cops. You're done
Someone's gonna be like a slam
praying man to cyclops that's green. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Give it a little bug pincers as well. Yeah, mommy doesn't hate a single thing. Have you checked her work? She seems to try everything
We're looking to hit every demographic not a niche. Yeah, I mean do we need a halfling when we have a cuttlefish that needs a steps
I'm not that small. I'm sorry, but five two is not that small. I'm literally bang on average height for the women in the world. Am I not?
Am I not as to if five point two not bang average on height
Just a slain blob. That's it
Every day you push me to form an insect slain cyclops feature agency
You just call it like I don't know what you should call it
just be like
V success and then the the point is to prove that you can have a
Successful beat of her as like this design. I think the average five four. Oh fuck me man V slimy. Okay, dude
Freaks Incorporated
V repel and they do the opposite repel
I've almost finished my thing V cute short
I'm starting to imagine that brain meme when you go to sleep saying that you have made a slime girl then
Oh, imagine if that was the biggest turnaround of the century that there's already a slime girl design approved
Hey, and I'm just pretending there isn't and I'm like, oh, I hate slime girls
See it
Can you tell me twice
Wouldn't that not be the the ultimate debate
I mean if I pulled that off I'm gonna make if I pulled that off I deserve like all the whole
Right, there's a lot of supplies in these barracks, which makes me think
I
Little bit hold on I need to lure the thing that would be such a dirty move five two is the global average in China
Oh my god, I can't believe you guys find out. I'm secretly Asian right now
Uh, I wasn't kidding when I said I had a Chinese and a
I
I really like her voice. I wish she voiced more video games. Maybe she has and I just don't know about it. Her voice is very
Well, I could not even see that in bed
No, just a few resupplies, okay, okay
I love it when she calls you sport
Oh, you're such a good sport little reflin even though I know you said that for the commentator
But I don't I've never like I've ever called the reflin
sport
Oh, you're such a good sport watch me play these games that absolutely no one cares about
Literally apparently I've made vtuber news by playing mech assault
I'll need a check if there really hasn't been a vtuber that's played mech assault. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa bring it back
Bring it back. Bring it back. Bring it back now. Yeah
Everybody
Oh, there's an
Okay, I forget that I can hold down a on this guy
Oh, I don't have an ultimate on this character
Wow, I don't there's no ultimate
There's no like defense or anything
Uh, I think I'd rather just found this
Oh, I'm taking a bit of damage
Oh my god, please stop. Oh my god, please stop
Stop. Oh my god, did you see those drinks?
Call me the call me a hazard because of the way I did those drinks. Oh
Oh
Okay, hold on. I've got purple on this but it's pretty leveled up to me
And it doesn't turn towards my
Are you just taking that? Yeah, are you going to take that? Oh, fuck. He's actually getting me crazy right now
Okay, and he puts that. Okay. Yeah. Good fuck me
Give me that hill
Get it. Get it. Jokes of hazard that that one movie that one tv show. No, it's a movie
I can't and then he wanted to like impregnate uh someone underage or something. I can't recall the details. I apologize
Yeah, you never heard of this. It was probably because my old school game knowledge is limited to nintendo
Watch it collapsing tunnel
Whoa, I didn't even know the game did things like that
That's cheeky. That's cheeky. No, you know how to do that only I'm allowed to do that
Damn that was loud was it? I'm so sorry the the game volume balance control. I actually might pin a comment
uh
There's something bad ahead of me. Oh, it's there
Where is it? What?
Hello
Whoa, the game did not like that angle I entered and it we've been around
She hasn't seen that before
Literally, that's the fact. Whoa, there's two mechs on the battlefield
Uh, I do not have infinite health. I'm gonna be honest. I do not have infinite health
Okay, come come back come back come back
Oh, and the trees are gonna blow come on down
Right come back over here
Fuck
Can you aim a little bit please?
And so for distancing, please please back up
If I back up is it fast enough?
Are you ready? Oh good. Oh good. Oh no. I'm out of special ammo. I'm down to red. I'm down to red. Hold on
I'm getting a blittery right now. I'm on the line
Hmm not enjoying this not enjoying this not enjoying this. I'm down. I'm down
I'm down. Oh god, please
Oh, I got special reds. I got special reds. Hold on
Fuck them up. Fuck them up. Fuck them up. Make them regret it. Make them regret it
Make them regret it. Oh god, he's getting some licks on me though. I don't like it. Oh, he's getting some decent licks on me
Please stop
Please please
Oh my god, please just freaking die. Thank you
Oh, I'm low health and I don't like it because I don't know where to get more health and I don't want to replay this whole section
Don't give up. You got this. Thank you. I think there must have been health in the distance because that was rough
Okay, I see health. I see health
Well, I see green give me that health give me that ammo
Give me whatever's in this building. What else do you owe for me?
Oh
Okay, okay, we can do this we can do
Oh, can I don't need to snipe it from here? No, that can't be right
Uh
Is this got a HP bar or am I
I don't really want to
No, wait, hold on. Oh wait, it's breaking
Okay, okay
Is there any enemies got a lot of enemies?
Whoa, that's such a unique noise
Only one more find it and we may be safe
Okay, one more. Is there any
special
Healing around the corner. No, okay. I guess we're not at that stage in video game development when we put like little secrets
No HP bar
That plank master
Okay
Only like there's anything
I'm getting nervous. I really don't want to
Well
I love how you look at
You're mostly male that ain't going nah guys hate giant robots. No, I'm not like that. Just like
I don't know. I feel like some v-tubers normally try and pick the most popular flavor of game
Or am I being daft when I say that unknown case?
An annoying helicopter squadron is this
Oh
Because
I can hear him, but I don't see
Oh
Oh, is that why I lost my health in that earlier match because of the
Curious
I hear a chopper. I don't see. Oh, I see it. I see it. I see it. Yeah, sorry
Haha, wouldn't it be so funny if you had help or like anything?
Having a good jolly time jolly good show
I don't care about popular games robots shooting each other. It's like popular to me
It's interesting if you actually like the game. Oh, you're gonna be melting for viva pinata then
Filled with fun filled with fun viva pinata
Wait, I'm not being dumb in the end then you go back then you go around then you do a u-turn
I think I do
You turn time
No, don't look on to me. Don't don't tell them. I'm here
Don't be silly
Don't tell them. I'm here. I saw that
I saw that
You got big mix. I'm just a wee make
That has very little help
We really appreciate it
Oh, I'm like really trying not to take any damage from anything at the moment
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'm not ready. Yeah. I'm not ready. Yeah. Hold on. I'm not ready for a mix
Hey, where are you coming up here?
Where are you here?
Oh god, I can't see him
Is he above I want to get licks in before he gets licks in on me
I don't
above or below
Reveal yourself. Hey, I meant
I'm a little bit slander right hold on. Whoa, there's two of them
Hold on. Can we do one at a time? Hold on. Hold on. Let's do one at a time. Let's make it easy
Let's make it fair. Come on. We're all lads here. We're all lads here. Get fucked. Get sniped. Oh, fuck that tree really took that
Yeah, yeah, take that tree. That's what we think of you nature. Ah
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let him get up. Let him get up. Let him get up. One be one. One be one
No, I'm not going around that corner. You are coming to me
You are coming
to me
right
no
I am not losing right at the end of this mission. I refuse. I'm sorry. I refuse. I actually refuse. Sorry. I refuse. I'm not losing
You are losing right now
I'm getting overheated. Sorry. I'm I'm not losing. I refuse. I refuse. Yeah. Yeah. That's right. That's right. Take it. Take it like a good meg
Take it
Okay, up next his best pal, but I have health right. Who is this?
Who is it?
Okay, we're fine
Oh
Okay, we're good. We're good. We're good. Oh my god. Please give me this like red fucking thing more for the rocket
Like the power up because that's insane
He's already low. Hold on. Hold on. Let me cool down mate. Mate. Hold pause. Pause. Let me time a shoe laces. Pause the fight
Come on. Save first mate. Save first
Come on. Come on
Yeah, we did it. Or I'd make a goblin hack and build a creature
Oh, no, please.
New mate
Oh
Hello, please don't be an atlas. I'm gonna ship myself
Ragnarok. No
Oh, I don't I've forgotten his name, but he's not nice. He's really you can't be sure and I'm not even in the freaking game
Stop stop stop pause stop. That's cheating. That's fucking cheating. Sorry. That's actually cheating
You were shooting me in the cutscene
Fuck off. Hold on. I'm overheating. Give me a second
Oh, hold on. I can't aim. Fuck it. Sorry. I can't aim. We're getting through the lake part. Can you back up?
Stop. Stop. I'm actually gonna lose right at the fucking end. Are you serious? Oh
Oh
I
It's a score. Okay. Oh, you'll never guess why this mission was called Thor. You'll never get
Hydration check. Oh my god. I almost lost that. I'm not being funny
I'll handle this briefing
Captain will have to restrict yourself from engaging the enemy
I know this goes against everything you big tough mech warriors are taught
Oh, it's an atlas. Oh my god, it's an atlas
From inside we should be able to add to their comm center and see what information we can acquire about the orbital guns
Then comes the part I haven't figured out how you get back
Suddenly I'm glad I'm not a mech warrior. Oh, no, it's an atlas atlas is our tanky is anything
My dad actually found a soft lock on this mission. He was so proud of himself when he showed me it
Um, oh
I'm actually getting nervous
I'm getting nervous the Thor successfully blends heavy firepower with maneuverability and a heavy mix chassis
Atlas casually doing what it does in lore making people shit their fans
my my dad's favorite mech was atlas and
Captain you're just outside of the base perimeter
So
Okay, don't shoot
Anyone and don't run over any tank either or a gentleman. Oh my god, they're tea posing. Look. I'm going. Look. I'm we tea posing
Oh, he's animated but the other guy isn't yeah, so do not stand on anyone or you get obliterated to the moon
So I'm literally not moving until this convoy goes away
Okay
Okay, I'm satisfied my aoe is not going to upset any of this
Steady easy easy. No, I am a friendly
Uh, yeah easy
Easy, okay snowplow coming in easy easy. We don't want to upset the balance of anything
I hope when strong he struggles you can just go. I'll literally get my dad on the phone right now
Hold on Ray was safe to move
We're going to take the the right side because there's nothing other right side
Take it easy. Yes. We're friendly. Oh god
Oh, I thought I was going to bounce me on his head. Oh, yeah
Right easy
Right stop
Do I get runes? Oh crap gently
Gently
Steady don't want to hurt the snowplow
He's got taxes to pay you need to hold 30 back of your income for tax purposes most of the time is 30
Easy
Oh
Ouch captain if they raise an alarm you best find the back door
They've created you access now get near the comm center and pray
Oh my god
Oh my god, please leave me alone a I please they may suspect something play it cool
I'm playing it cool. I'm getting ready to fucking gear up
But I need to get near the comm center
There should be like five clicks
Stop AI is already targeting me. It's already targeting me
Oh, no, what is the countdown for?
Oh, sorry my apologies. Okay. Okay, panicking. I don't remember much this map
Friendly Thor, please transmit your ID code. Uh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh, uh ID code
We do not have the information yet to stay inside the base until we get the intel
Again friendly Thor, please transmit the code
Captain hang tight. We're almost there get ready to move out fast
Where do I move out to?
Almost
Where
I fucking wasn't ready. Is that the door? Hold on. I think the door is over here. Please let me out. Please let me out
I don't want to go against an outlet. I'm scared. Oh, I'm gonna get some Alice. What did I do?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, like this not like this. How'd I get out? Oh, wait, I can fly I can fly
No, I'm hay-bound. I'm hay-bound. Oh, no. I don't know where I'm supposed to go
Alice that he go back over the Alice came from
Um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, wait, I'm supposed to destroy those. No, no, no
I can get it
We just supposed to go the way the atlas came in okay restart
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's get to it. I'm sure I can
outpace everything. It implied the gates were going to open. It bloated, didn't. Was that
supposed to go out those gates? Anyone here put Mexico? Either pass the atlases or blow
up the generator to open the other gate or go back and... If I go out the atlases thing,
I assume they want to fight me. I just want to make sure I don't upset any little ground
soldier unit. I think the door... Oh my god, you have to... Right. At least not over the
generator's located, but... Did I even have the health to get out of there? Is my question...
Okay. So... Okay. No alarm is raised. So begin... So go there and then I'm going to aim at the
freaking generator and then I'm just gonna go for it because there's not much I can do.
Okay. Right. Okay. And then the generator was around this corner. Okay. Okay. You don't need to tell me
that there's enemies. I know there's enemies. Are you winning? We got rigged. We got really
badly rigged. They fight you either way. The atlas is gonna hit you with so many bullets for trying
to get away. Yeah. Oh god. What's my B? Oh god. Yes. Yes. Friendly. I'm friendly. I'm friendly. I'm
friendly. I'm so nervous and scared. I'm freaking trying. I'm in position four, three, two, one.
Uh-huh. Okay. I'm hiding behind this for now. Open. Please open. Please open. Please open. Please
open. Please open. Are you fucking serious? Open! I'm going, but I'm so slow. What does this mean?
I'm going. I'm going. I'm going. Oh god. Please close the gates behind me. Please close the gates
behind me. I beg of you. Be close the gate or something. I don't know. Ring the guards.
Anything. Please. There's too many of them. I can't do it. Oh my god. This is getting worse. There's
an enemy ahead. Oh, but there's health on the road. Okay. Okay. The guards have been rang. The guards
have been rang. Fight. Fucking gone. You didn't have to tell me twice, darling. I'm fucking gone.
I'm with the wind. I'm with the sky. I hate these kind of omissions. Oh god. Right. We're getting
farther. We're getting farther. That's the main thing. Okay. Across the bridge. Across the bridge.
Surely, I have to get across the bridge. There's only one way through. The only way out is through
a heavily breamed port to be ravine. Follow this in an actual application point. Down there. Oh,
shy saw. I'm one HP in a dream. How is I supposed to win this? I'm going to have to look up a tutorial.
Whoa. I'm dead. Whoa. Is that supposed to go down the river? I think I'm going down the river.
Wait. All I have to do, I don't actually have to do anything. I just have to reach the extraction
point. Hmm. Curious. Curious. The trucks dropped the hill. You've made good progress.
That was a good attempt. I think I'm to go bottom right at that river.
Oh, the trucks dropped health. The trucks. Okay, trucks. Look for a truck.
I think that path was right. There was a natural cover around the bend. Okay.
Just around the river bend. Strony, maybe time to ask your dad what he did. Honestly,
I don't remember him playing this mission a lot, so I don't think he enjoyed it.
Which I'm not even trying to agree with his taste in mission because WTF, mate.
We need mission control. Papacult is mission control. Right, let's go.
That took so long for the gate to open. I'm going to hide behind the generator this time,
so I don't take any damage at all. Counter started. I'm going to go behind the generator this time.
There is a health pack right there. Can I shoot? I'm wondering if I should take that off on the way out.
Okay, right side, there's a health pack when I leave. Oh, this truck has health.
ID code. What do you mean comply? Get ready to move out. Okay, green trucks have health in it.
Who do you think, huh? Okay. Three, two, one, go. I'm fucking trying. I'm trying. I'm trying.
I'm trying. I'm trying. I'm trying. I'm trying. I'm trying. I'm trying. Fucking hell, this is
generator. Have someone come see. Oh, come on. Break already.
Oh, is it broken? Okay, okay. So what, do you give me health?
You're a lie. Okay, okay. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine that there's two atlases locked onto me.
It's not a problem at all, as if that building could support the weight of my mech.
Sorry, my mech is far too heavy for it. Oh, no, it just takes so much damage because I walked into
that structure. Oh, my God, there's three heal stations.
Wait, do you have health? Or is it the other ones that have health? Who the fuck is sniping me from
the sky? I can't get a break, bro. I don't think I can actually do this. You, you, give me the health.
Give me the health. You don't understand. You don't understand. You are mine. You are mine. Give
me the health right now. I'm going. I'm going. I'm going. Great. Okay, health on the bridge.
The only way, oh, I got stuck on that turret again. Oh, God, I'm like one health already. I'm half
health already. Please stop shitting me. Oh, there's a green truck ahead. Get the truck.
Get the truck. Beat it up. Give me that truck. Give me that HP right now. Give me that health.
Fuck you. Beach. Fuck you, beach. Fuck you. Just think I won't do it.
God, that thing has some health on it. Wait, I'm supposed to go down. Wait, I'm confused. No,
up. Go up. Go up. Wait, give me a truck. Give me a truck. I'm half health. Give me a truck. Come on.
Come on. Let me get a range. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
I'm so good at this health. There's health. I see it. I see it. I see it. I see it. I see it.
Shit. Shit's a base. Shit's a bomb car. What are you doing? Oh, my God. Oh, there's another one.
Oh, we're going to make it. We're going to make it. I have hope. I have hope. Fricking shoot it,
though. Oh, wait, sorry. I'm flying. Wait, that's why I can't shoot it. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I'm
panicking. Panicking. Right. You. Fuck off. Oh, God, there's a new makeup ahead. No,
you're not supposed to do that. Stop. Stop. You're making me so stressed. Oh, I see health. I see
health. I see. I see green. I see green. I see green. I see green. I'm doing great. Yeah. Yeah,
I'm not panicking at all. I'm not panicking at all. It's fine. It's fine. No, I'm MLG at this game.
It's fine. Oh, God, the HUD is breaking. The HUD is breaking. Why? There's so much. Okay, I see green.
I see green. I see green. I see green. I see green. I see green. I see green. I see lots of green. I
actually quite like seeing this much green. I have to admit, this is pretty cool. Yes, you better
have a plan to get me out. Okay, okay. Destroy the bridge when I'm on the other side. Oh, that's a
freaking atlas. It's an atlas. It's an atlas. But break the bridge. Break the bridge. Break the bridge.
I'm on the other side of the bridge. The bridge. The bridge. The bridge. The bridge. Destroy the
bridge. The motherfucking bridge. Oh, you suck so bad. Why do you suck so bad? Oh, no. Oh, no, it's
all coming. Oh, why are you not destroying? No, don't lock onto the atlas. Fuck it. No, not like
this. Not like this. Oh, no, I have to destroy the bridge to progress. Why? Why would you do
this to me video game? Why? The bridge was hardly breaking. I was so close to dying. I was so close.
No, I can't 1v1 a fucking atlas. No, why does the bridge die? Why does the ace have so much
damage? Why does the bridge have so much HP?
Because the rocket did very little damage? Yeah, well, your mom. I did it. I won the game.
I won that fucking mission. You suck. You stinky game. You know I blew up that bridge.
Freakin' have to use something else.
This make only fires two at a time. So much for having make superiority with this one. It sucks.
Stony, your spam flying is slowing you down a lot and overheating you.
Oh, but I feel like if I fly, they don't hit me as much.
Shoot the bridge as you walk across it because it has so much. Okay, I agree with this
sentence. I approve of this message. Oh, excuse me. Sorry, you didn't see that. I promise I'm
trained in this make and I haven't just put it on for the first, I haven't been inside it for the
first time. Great. I will use X in zero.
Oh, let me reset.
I freaking bumped a building. I'm in a massive make. Fucking give me a chance. How did I get
even worse? Literally, I kicked it. If you hit every health pick up along the way and just run
serpentine, it'll be enough to get you there. Okay, okay, okay. We can do it. We can do it.
We can do it. We can do it. We can do it. We can do it. We can do it. We can do it. We want.
Yeah, missiles have the least damage against these. The laser works better.
Great. I can do it. I have faith. If there's any doubters,
then doubters will be recommended to go watch V-Slammy V-Tubers instead of
Viller Beach. Oh, that's so stressful. Right, stop flying. It slows me down.
Okay, I can do this and I can not hit a building on the way there.
All I have to do is not spank a building and then I just need to run.
I'm sure someone's probably done this where he has killed everything before. I'd actually
be very curious to see if someone's got gameplay of that. Okay. Stop AI locking onto me. You smell.
I know what you're doing. I know what you are.
Oh, hold on. Okay.
Right, we're hacking into the comms unit. Slime arachnid V-Tuber with only one eye and a green
skin, surely. Would we be able to do this mission on the first try? I said mods. Take that man out
for 10 seconds. How dare he speak like that to me. How dare. Okay, we can do this. There's a
little green truck here. If I really need it, then there's also a green one.
I'm so terrified about it. You have got this, I believe in you. This is it. This is the run.
This is the run because I'm using my X now.
Okay, that was so much quicker. Right, don't use your fly. Stop panicking. Stop flying. Use it.
Okay, I can do that. I can do that. Right, hold on. We'll get some coverage going through here.
Pardon me, coming through. Okay, and then there's a health station to the left as I come out here.
Oh my gosh, did I just mess up again? Oh, I think so.
Oh, I'm running.
Why did they have to make such a stressful mission? You! Give me, oh wait, there's one here too.
Right, and then you're next. You're next.
I'm fate. What fate? I'm fucking getting annihilated. There is no fate. There's only death and
stinkiness. Is there even a health station? There isn't. Oh, you're the health pack. Okay, I found you.
Right, I can shoot the bridge as I go along it because, no, not this one, the next bridge. Sorry.
Next bridge, next bridge. Oh, something just splattered me for heavy. I don't know what it was, but it got me good.
Okay, okay.
Oh, ow, ow, that actually took a decent considerable chunk of damage. Ow, please stop, please stop.
Please, I'm such a good feature, I'm such a good feature bird. Please, please,
God, stop taking tick damage. It's all I ask, please.
Stop it. I don't even know what the pylons do when they spot you. Oh god, there's one there.
Wait, well, why did all the other freaking mechas time out? Okay, one's on, one's hot on my R-Streets.
I don't even know if I can pick this up. You can't even beat over Healed Canyon in those games. No,
you can't. I'm full health. Okay, take it as a blessing. I'm full health. I'm full health. Take it as a blessing.
Oh yeah, I'm full health. I'm full health. I don't fucking care.
Go away. I don't know what the wee towers do, but I'm going for it. I'm going for it. I'm trying my best.
I'm a good little mate, and I am doing great. Thank you. Okay, where the fuck do I go?
Hello? Should I fuck up? I'll weave it. I'll weave it. It's okay. Back on course, back on course, back on
course. Let him get up. Let him get up. Let him get up. Okay, I see it. I see the hell.
Ah, no game. Don't break now. I'm almost there. Don't do that to me. Don't be so selfish. Okay.
Okay. I'm trying. I'm trying. I'm breaking free. I'm solving. I'm trying.
There's not a bridge. There's gaining. Freaking. Come on, mate. Come on, mate. Pop already.
Come on. Come on. Yes. Fucking shove up your ass. Atlas. Fucking bam.
Can you get this one too? I don't know if I need to do this one too, but I think I'm okay. Okay.
Okay. Oh my god, we did it. We just need to destroy this one, which I can do. Oh my god,
we did it. Yeah. Okay. That's fine. That's fine. Oh, we did it.
Oh.
Wait a second. Holy crap. Sirs, I know what the word of Blake is doing on this planet.
They found some sort of lost technology cache and something called Ragnarok.
No. I'm going to signal the other dragoons. Ragnarok is even scarier than Atlas.
Oh, no. We know where the guns are. Now we need to stop them before the invasions of the
dragons are on. Wait, isn't the dragon the name of Dokey Bird?
Oh, she got a new outfit. And a familiar model.
Work your way towards the orbital gun any way you can and then destroy the gun.
Oh, it's letting me pick.
I'm going to say I didn't actually enjoy Thor that much, but Timberwolf.
Timberwolf has so much spray and pray though with those things. I'll try with Timber,
if not, I'll take on the other one. You don't remember the Ragnarok? Okay,
so think of Thor and then change everything by two.
I like how they cut coms on him.
Right. Again, we might lose it.
Sir, you're going to face stiff defense. You may be able to skirt around the worst
of it with a maneuverable mech. I don't care what you do, Captain. Get those guns.
We have a tamer. If they eat the worst, well, well, well,
if there's in the worst kind of game, well, they can give you a fricking tamed mission.
Right. I can't fly. Maybe I should.
Shit. Nothing's open. Huh?
I can't fly. Wait. I softlocked myself because I have something that can't fly.
Stop. Wait, can I destroy these walls?
Can I open this door for Mimi? I'd appreciate that.
I think I, unironically, think I need to start with the new mech.
Right. Okay, hold on. Quit mission. Yeah.
And then, okay, it was under the guns. We know where the guns are.
Right. That's fine. And then give me mad cat, I guess.
Mad cat. Well, Thor can fly as well.
Sir, the new tool we're receiving is the heavy firepower.
Straight through with one of our big gun mechs or take a jump capable mech and skirt around
the edge of the base. Your call. Time is of the essence. The other dragoons are counting on you.
I'll try mad cat. See behind. Wait, mad cat can't fly.
Oh, right. Sorry. Sorry. Let's try that again. Mad cat can't fly. Thor can fly.
We will pick Thor. Dumb. Dumb, dumb, dumb.
We know where the guns are. One more time for the, one more time from the top.
Thor can fly. So we can fly over. Wow. You didn't think it was that hard.
Don't forget, lasers are the structure busters. You can break the door.
I didn't know that. Right. Hold on. We're using the laser beam. I'm a fire on the laser.
Right. I'm going to all lock onto the retanks because it's just so much easier all alone.
Whoa. This hardly does any damage on the all alone. Man, I want a mad cat so bad. They do so much
damage like all alone. I mean, I like not having to try sometimes. Is that, is that so hard?
Yes, you're a dumb, dumb, but you're a dumb, dumb, affectionately, affectionately, affectionately,
though. Okay. So there's a health pack. I know a mad cat comes in. There's actually two health packs.
That's a lot of resistance. Wow.
Oh, here. I mean, this is, this is all locking on him pretty quickly. I have to say, I have to say,
it's not, oh, that was some juicy damage he just did there. I don't know what my ultimate is,
but I'll use it anyway. Wait, he's even sparking yet. I feel like I've done, who the fuck is shooting
that? Fuck off! Honestly, doing my fucking hits in.
Hold on, let me please redeem his ass. Oh, sugar. I'm out of, um, oh, he's limping?
Is he limping? I think we're doing it. I think we're doing it. Okay. God, this is taking far too
long. I think I'm wasting so much time doing this. Like, game-wise, I should not be doing,
oh my God, he's literally about to get, about to get each other. We're actually having like a decent
break, yeah. And there's an enemy behind me. What the heck? What am I supposed to do? Oh,
I'm supposed to go north? Oh, fuck off. Right, you, fuck you. I don't, uh, I don't know if I should
send it or not, but given you a timed mission, surely the game devs wouldn't be so evil to give
you a timed mission and then give you a billion mechs in front of you for the past, so you're
perfectly run out of time and you have to redo the whole 15-minute mission again.
Surely. Surely for an old ass, I don't even know when this game came out. I probably wasn't even
born when I came out. No, I can't do it. Maybe. Because I never played it when I watched my dad
run out of time. Can a mech be left alone to do their job exactly? Is this the right way?
No, this is just a fiber.
Me. How do I, do I fly? Oh, I can fly. Oh, it's fantastic.
Uh, yeah, I think I've taken some kind of shortcut to the mountain. The good news.
Uh, okay, okay, okay.
I am a little bit sparky.
Okay, okay. Okay, I know there's a mech down there. Hold on. Hold on, you're next, mate. Hold on.
Oh, are you freaking serious? Uh, can't be arsed when the AI is like hiding. Oh, and I just took a
direct hit off something. Lovely. Oh, I don't know if I should be fighting you or not. Oh no.
Right, you're just backing off. I don't know why. Sorry, mate, it was not working.
I think the laser's on when you put that down. Sorry. Please just take these direct hits, please.
I'm begging, please so I can pick up your freaking health. I need it. I need it. I need it. Give me
your health. Okay, we're just kind of, yeah, okay, we're just gonna do this, yeah? I'm trying.
He's not perishing. Okay, there we go. Give me that health. Give me that health. Okay, I'll pick it.
Yeah, and you guys are fucking next. We're slowly getting damaged in the middle of that fight.
Uh, we're doing the wrong way. I'm supposed to be going this week. Can you take fall damage?
I'm getting nervous. I'm getting shaky. Uh, literally, uh, the guy knew it was inevitable.
Right, another mech, but I can see the cannon. Okay, there you are. Fuck me. That's not good.
You guys are so cheap. Like, why do you guys get two, but I only get one?
The boys? Captain, help me out, question mark. The mad cat is currently going around me to
sandwich me. Can you see it on the hard bottom left? The mad cat is going around to freaking
sandwich me. I'm not even kidding. Sorry, I think I'm gonna have to move into this health part.
Yeah, the mad cat is getting me from behind. I'm not happy with that. I don't know.
No, do not randomly swap fucking magazines for that. Oh, come on. Call the weak guy at least.
Sir. Oh, I'm running out of time. Oh, I'm completely out of fucking. Oh.
Oh, face of maneuvers. A face of maneuvers. That's so loud behind me. Please stop. Please stop.
Hold on. I'm over the edge. Oh, but when I jump, right, blow them up. No, I didn't do any
freaking environmental damage against them. I would very much like to win this mission in one go.
I do not want to replay this mission. I'm going to be honest.
I took, like, so much direct damage there. I'm so, the overheat is, like, punishing me so hard right
now. And, of course, I never made it. I was a waste of time. Oh, right. Hold on. He's smoking.
He's smoking. That's what you get for smoking. Oh, my God. I think I'm gonna have to jump this
chicken wall to not get hit by this fight again. Hold on. Oh, I need to get over. There we go.
Fuck you. Fuck you. I need to kill. Oh, I'm going to get direct hit off the spam.
How much have I got? About eight minutes to destroy this and the next one. I don't like mods.
Yeah, you better start limping. You have, you have, limping, limping, limping.
Fucking destroy this. I've got seven minutes to find the last one.
Oh, sorry. Right. Hold on. Where is it? Where? Where? Where? Where? This way? It says this way. Hold on.
If I go up. Oh, there it is. Oh, my God. There it is. It's right there. Holy crap. We can do it.
We can do it in one. We can do it in one. Now, let it spawn eight billion mints all at once for me to
perish. Sorry, you're going down. You're actually going down. I don't care what you're shooting at me.
You're going down first. Whoo. The orbital guns were our primary mission, but we got another one from upstairs.
So they aren't our yet. The Icarus isn't fixed enough to get us off-planet, but it can move us around.
Command wants us to figure out what this Ragnarok is and seize the lost technology
while the rest of the vehicles are at the word of Blake here. So we're off to a hellish wasteland
of lava and dust storms. Once more into the breach, A-Tiger. Once more. I'd rather be. We did it.
Whoa, we did it. Oh, they give you like double the time. Okay. The new case of our mission.
What's the name of this mission? Size Mars? Gambling, whatever floats your boat.
Size Mars. We did it. I'm so glad. If you just need the last one, you can take your
odds and bomb us. As you know, we are en route to the wasteland. We have received some intel that
got me thinking, and I have a plan. Oh, great. First, we have an old two-power armor in
hold. Captain, you are just the right size. That added to the fact that we've learned that
a number of word of Blake dignitariers are having some sort of celebration during an invasion.
Remember that time I actually did the plan. In this power armor, their sensors won't pick you up.
The bad guys won't go on full alert. You will face defenders just not their whole force. Get
through their base and find their mechs. Steal one, and then you'll be inside their defenses,
giving them hell before they know it. Steal a mech. Move through the small city,
demolish the regional palace, and crash their little party. What can I say? Brilliant.
Steal a mech. Can I steal an alice? Elemental, a suit of powered... Oh, that makes me want to play
cameo. Sorry. A suit of powered battle armor. An elemental is no match for mechs in single...
Who goes out? Combat. Hmm. Hmm. My size matters.
Let me defense should be minimal, though I recommend you stay away from combat.
Whoa, I'm so cute. Oh my god. I'm so cool. Oh, look at me go. Oh, I'm so fast. Holy crap. Like,
but I don't have much thrusters to me. Oh, I'm so cute. Oh, sorry. Wait, what are you...
What even armor? Is something shooting me? There is. Whoa, I can hear it.
What did I do?
What sort of scraps do I...
I hear. Whoa, I have so much lift.
Scissors and enemy over here. Whoa. Okay, thank goodness fall damage in a mech suit isn't a thing,
because... There's something red over here, so I assume that's where I'm supposed to go.
Whoa. Whoa, who, who, who, who? Oh my god, so this is what it's like to be like a tiny
big round unit. Okay, we got him. Who next? Wait, I didn't get him. It's so rich.
Wow.
Up here?
Sorry, I don't really have much of a recollection of this at all.
Oh.
Am I going too fast for you? Too bad. Plop, plop, plop, plop. Oh, there's a wee baby one.
That's what we're fainting. Okay, hold on, wait, wait, hold on, let me get into the fight.
Geeze, is this Out of Bones? Is that why? I think this might be Out of Bones and
he's like an invisible wall. Well, I got a lick off on someone. Oh crap, how'd I get around?
Sir, I'm reading an incoming mech. Somewhere. It must be using no sig. Captain, you can't fight him.
Get a move on. No, no, don't give me a run and map again. I get too stressed out when you give me
run maps. Wait, what the heck am I supposed to...? Something's dying behind me. I'm so confused
where I'm supposed to go. I'm so sorry, guys. This door? Okay, is this like maybe a generator
to open a door? There's two mechs after me now. Whoa, whoa, whoa, I can hear it freaking
charging up against me. You just relaxed me. What am I supposed to do?
Sorry, I'm probably gonna die, but it's too too confusing rather than being bad.
Well, I am bad, but I don't... Is there something back there?
Was I supposed to kill a generator?
Huh. There's three. Just run, but run where? Oh, shit.
Oh, my, my gear is on for registering now. Oh, okay, it's registering again. Hold on.
Am I just wee enough that they can't shoot me? Well, they can shoot me a wee bit, but where am I?
Sorry, sorry. Let me just focus on the map detail, because they wouldn't put sections in the map
if they weren't supposed to go near it, kind of. Right, so it is that gate, but how do I get over it?
All right, I'm low health, that's all.
You mean you're confused because of how good I am at the same exact...
Is it... And before it just opens... Oh, for fuck's sake! Come on!
As if that was the solution! I was joking! Oh, of course it was. I wasted so much health,
no. I don't know if I'll make it run through. Yeah, they don't even drop health because we're so
Chinese. Oh, well, oh well. Okay, we'll try again next run. At least we know the gate opens.
Good job, sir. Had me sweating. You were sweating, briefing boy.
Let me guess, this break, it kind of looked breakable.
Or not. Oh, it's a shame they don't give you a health pack anywhere.
Right, we'll know much better than for next time.
Hmm. Okay, so come down the lava path, they take a little lift.
When in doubt, just walk out. Once again, Stroney assumes she can't go somewhere without trying.
I mean, every other part of the game has been like, you can't go there, you must destroy
something in order to do it. So, XK is... So, as I was saying, XK is me.
For, um, assuming otherwise.
I am definitely getting Kablamo's, like, right now by that guy.
In a cavern. Secret cavern. Secret cavern. Fly away from the loofy.
The Cougar. Secret, secret, secret, secret cavern.
How am I doing this on one HP? Seriously, drop me at least one HP.
Like, don't be shy, game. Don't be shy. Drop me one HP.
All of it? All of it feels good, man. Have I cornered myself? Be honest.
I haven't cornered myself. I need to keep going. Keep going.
We're breaking free. We're so good.
There's no a-me-king.
Uh, a tank. I can handle a tank in my wee baby armor.
I can handle a tank. Look, Zia, just scream free.
I'm praying. I'm praying. I'm praying. I'm praying. I'm praying.
See? All is good. This game, I ain't got nothing to worry about in my little elemental guy.
I'm so tiny and cute, okay? I need to stop flying. I need to destroy these guys.
Wait, there's someone behind me? It's Zia! Naughty. You're not supposed to go behind me.
Hold on. Wait, wait, wait. Hold on. I don't have infinite health.
If you could all just group up and stop and start missing your shots, that would be great.
Please, group up and start missing your shots. Thank you.
This has been... Oh no, the cougar is coming up to me.
Better get a move on. The cougar is chasing me.
P.O.V., you're a college boy in the classic American popcorn film.
The cougar is coming for me.
See? See? They said blast the building because the gate is controlled by it.
Does that actually mean that, or did it not mean that? Oh, this, sorry.
The comb's coming. Let me in. What's in here? Other than...
Jackpot, kid in a candy store. Captain, um, Captain, stop window shopping. The Atlas will do fine.
Atlas time! Let's see how we do with this stop, boy.
Whoa. Hello. Daddy's home.
Okay, let's see. Oh, next mission.
No, still same. Still same.
I remember.
Okay, I don't want to waste too much ammo on that stuff.
Okay.
Oh, one hit, baby.
Well, I bet he regrets it now.
Show em' this. Size max.
Whoa, it's probably the...
Wait, hold on. How do I aim?
Okay. Holy. Holy schmooze.
Holy schmooze. No, back up. I hate when they do that.
Stop. Hey, dang.
I'm overheating. Oh, my God. The Atlas has very limited mobility.
Holy crap. Like, even turning to look at him? Very limited.
Okay. Enough out of YouTube.
Jeez. Let's see what we got here.
Okay, there we go. Yeah, the mobility is like,
whoa, it's rough trying to do it.
But I actually like that detail being like,
oh, I almost fell into the lava. You didn't see that.
And I like that it feels like, oh, you know.
The only thing about that was we caught him napping.
Punch through that weakened wall section.
We caught him napping? Sure.
Right, let's see what we're up against.
Right, it's a few tanks. Nothing that I can't even do.
Whoa, there's...
You take forever to shoot for how...
Please.
Nope, you do not need to start destroying the natural rock foundation.
As fine as it is.
Here's the next.
That's a barrier.
I complete this game all day.
Has everything just got more HP all of a sudden?
Oh, wait. Oh, it's just a cougar.
Uh, I'm scared.
I don't like the lack of mobility.
I'm talking about... Where is it? Oh, it's down there.
Okay, he's in the lava? Hello?
Are you hurting yourself?
Oh, make it rain hell.
Oh, please.
Okay, I'm completely comprehend why the Atlas was my dad's favorite mate.
Because, oh my goodness.
Literally make it rain.
Yeah.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, hold on.
What's this one?
Oh, wow. That's actually really overpowered as well.
Is there any health pack for troops during this one?
You look like... Yeah, we got it.
Lack of mobility makes up for the HP, the armor,
and then the four death rays attached.
Also, real guns.
Yes, I quite agree.
Wait, am I going down there?
I came from there.
Yeah, question mark.
Was this the one that got him all the wins on multiplayer?
Yeah.
Wait, I must be...
I didn't say I must be supposed to go through the lava,
but I didn't see it, right?
Right.
Oh, I see it.
Can I get it before it gets me?
I can.
You too?
Oh, it's so nice being able to reach the enemy before the enemy gets you.
Oh, shit.
See something in the distance?
It's very blurry.
I don't know how blurry it is for you, but...
The mech just...
The mech.
The enemy just like...
Whoa.
Look at that.
That's so nice.
Right. Hold on.
Okay, let's go.
Mech time.
Who are we against in this lovely enemy?
I think because of his health being so low,
we're just gonna blow this guy down.
Easy, easy.
And actually, we could probably drop the bridge on him.
You know that?
Oh, I want his health outside the lava though.
Yeah, there we go.
No, don't go in the lava.
Sugar.
He fell back and...
Well, it's not like we need a major HP.
I don't know.
Maybe we can touch it gently.
Easy.
Just tip two.
Hey, we go.
Right, we're dead.
I'm gonna break the bridge so the lava isn't a problem.
Because I don't want to lose health the lava.
I can't...
I see nothing.
Yeah, it's a very cloudy game.
I...
I guess we did.
It's kinda a bit cloudy.
Is this not gonna break?
Can you break it?
Lasers will break it faster.
I'm gonna hold it off for the mech.
I assume...
Well, I assumed completely wrong.
I am actually gonna have to walk in the lava a little bit.
Oh wait, no, no.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
I just love making things harder for myself,
clearly, because spending the time to do that
only to yield absolutely nothing is pretty good.
That's not good enough.
Right, I've been given special services.
Partygoers?
Where?
Oh, here.
Uh...
In here?
Whoa!
That's the lava in me that came out of nowhere.
Are you these guys?
One...
Oh, there's a mech on the battlefield.
Hold on.
Mech first.
Oh, hold on.
Two!
Atlas!
Is that an Atlas or a Magiskun?
Scoot's Freddy.
Okay.
Is that an Atlas?
No.
It's just tangible.
No, it is an Atlas!
Oh, dear.
Little Atlas moment.
Tee hee.
Great.
So what do I need to do?
Take my one by one,
and then just hook up all their insides.
And then your neck.
Wah.
Not good, not good.
I can't see nothing bumping.
Pick it up, whatever it is.
Okay, we're just gonna do this on the Atlas.
It's the best we've all.
Right, Atlas down first.
Hold on.
Is he smoking yet?
I'd rather you smoke first than me, buddy.
To be honest.
Nah, let's rubbish that.
Right.
See you!
Oh, sugar.
I'm low health.
Not good, not good, not good.
Oh, it would suck if I had to restart.
Come on, one big chug!
One big chug on him!
No, stop flying, mate, stop flying.
Give me your health, give me your health.
Oh, right.
Give me your health then,
if you're gonna go down first.
Please!
I'm on my knees!
Oh, sugar.
I have to literally walk into this guy's bullet.
Oh, that was so lucky I managed to cut that health.
Holy crap.
Wah.
Wah, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky.
Sorry, it's not luck at all.
It's skills, complete and utter skills.
I'm the daughter of a meccosalt prodigy.
I will not have anything else.
Right, I'm gonna look for any green buildings
through the absolutely smoky haze that is this game.
Holy, holey moley.
I cannot see for the life of me.
Any green at all.
Like, seriously, any green at all.
Or any hidden green, no.
Am I okay?
That was worth it.
What is that off the head?
What is?
Oh, I upset something.
Hold on, how do I get around?
Just firing, I'm just firing.
How do I get around?
Is there no around?
Is there only through?
Sorry, my mobility's so slow that I'm trying to...
Oh god, this looks like the path though.
Oh, dumb ass, there's a path right there.
I hope that there's something that's able to shoot me.
Yeah, lucky shot, not lucky shot at all.
As, eh, right, hold on.
And then there's one over there.
Can I see it?
Nope, but you can see me or not?
Nope, I missed.
Something blew on my HUD.
Bottom left, top left.
Sorry, I'll let him bolt for health or something.
Destroy this.
I'd rather...
Oh, I want to save my other ammo.
Whoa, it makes the team out.
I can't see him.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I can moan down, I can moan down, I can moan down, it's fine.
Oh god, he's got...
I'm overheating like hell on there.
Hold on, mate, can you just pause the fight?
Pause the fight, I need a heal.
Sorry, I need a...
Not good, not good, not good.
Oh god, he's burning though.
That's what I want to see.
That's what I want to see, not me though.
We're doing it, we're doing it, we're doing it, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
True protg, momento.
Right, what's going on here?
Did I not successfully destroy that?
I don't really want to...
I don't want to...
All is quiet.
The Blake brass has been eighty-six years fled.
All combat forces have been in the way.
Okay, okay.
Wow, that's why I want to hold on to the ch-ch-ch-ch-amel
because it's soon.
Was it too much to ask that that lunatic was at the party?
Captain, we are en route to your current position.
The Major has decided to bring the Icarus down right where you are.
Foster, let's try not to crash this time, eh?
Okay, a little slo-mo, a little slo-mo.
Okay.
We've obtained information that more suspected rebels
are being made to work in factories reinforcing the word of Blake.
Uh-huh.
We can kill two birds with one stone
by freeing the prisoners and destroying the factories.
We're going to hot-drop you in, sir.
Destroy local forces between you and the camp.
Secure escape, bro.
Take the camp towers out and, as always, flatten any hostile troops.
Okay, I'm gonna take a hydration.
Everyone please do hydrate.
Shawnee destroys your mech and takes you as a trophy ASMR win.
How rich do you have to be to build a mansion in a volcano?
I mean, why would you even want a mansion in a volcano?
Ugh.
Okay, I've hydrated.
Uh, right, let's see.
Okay.
Well, an assault class mech, the Atlas is an offensive force rarely matched.
Yeah, sorry.
I'm picking Atlas.
If we're gonna get a lot of this,
game does a good job of making these bad guys seem bad.
I hope I'm not the bad guy.
Well, we're already on mix fight.
Hold on, there's a wee guy there.
Can you all lock on him?
Thank you.
Did we chop her as well while we're at it?
Hold on.
What?
Nope.
That's not gonna attack me.
Okay.
That's currently installing mods to give me extra XP to use.
XP is XP, is that it?
Wah, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, hold on.
I think this might, oh wow, that shotgun blast definitely is the one.
Get out of the lava so I can at least scavenge your dead parts.
Come on.
Yeah.
Oh no, I can't pick it up.
It broke the magma.
Ah, draft.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine.
Racing for racing, but it's fine.
Can't pick up the supply.
Okay, the magma breaks.
I assume it will break under the weight of my mix.
You know, all things considered, I probably weigh how many tons?
On ironically?
I don't want to waste too much of the shotgun.
The shotgun seems so effective against the enemies.
I can see you guys.
I can't target you.
I wonder why it's not enjoying the targeting as much.
Hmm.
Oh wow, that's actually a decent chunk, so I mean, hold on.
Stop it, stop it.
No, no, no, don't hide from me now.
You started the fight.
I'm gonna end it.
Do you understand your actions have consequences?
You're gonna find out now.
Goodbye.
And I'm here if you were following orders.
You're done for.
How much have I got?
Oh wait, I've got infinite bullet ammo as well.
But I've only got...
Oh wow, okay, sorry, I'm just gonna use the...
Who have I got?
Okay, let's get rid of you and then let's get started on you.
But you'll need to come down so I can pick up your supplies, okay?
Yeah, that's exactly what I want.
Okay, perfect.
I...
No, no, no, no, you're gonna...
Can the game kill itself in lava?
Hold on.
I need you to pick up your stuff.
I'm not even kidding.
Please, just perish.
Come on, please, game.
Wow.
100 tons of Atlas, I believe it.
How much health?
How much heal?
Like that.
Right, yeah.
We're just shotgun.
You're totally crap.
The shotgun on the Atlas is something else.
You know, I didn't even tell my dad I'm playing this game
because they are probably filming after the stream
if it's not too late.
I'll be like,
stop!
I think it's an outpost.
You're right to the outpost comm tower.
Dust it.
It'll be kicking me off the PC
so you can play it, actually, when it gets here.
But now...
Come on.
Stop it.
There's so many wee ones.
But their damage adds up.
Like, that's the problem with it.
I add up.
Where's that?
Oh, my God, I see it.
No, and it saw me.
Drap.
What's going on here?
I don't...
Why is there so many health stations?
Why is there so many health ups?
There are, like, six around me.
Hold on.
How many am I?
I don't know.
Oh.
That's why.
Because there's a new mech coming in the way.
Where are you?
I'm using my ultimate.
Don't worry.
Ow!
But you're not even on my side of the map.
Wait.
Who or what is shooting me?
There's, like, something tiny shooting me.
I can hear it!
Oh.
Hold on.
Oh, wait.
That doesn't do anything against the new repellent thing.
I wish we were there.
What?
Are we going to do it?
Oh, my gosh.
I feel like, because we've got Atlas unlocked,
we actually might be close to finishing the game.
Right.
You!
Fuck off!
Holy crap.
Uh.
Oh, no.
Hold on.
Did I just unlock a memory?
Uh.
We may or may not be in for an absolute heck on earth fight coming up.
With an intense amount of enemies.
Do you think we can break these doors?
I just realized I think I remember this map,
and this might be the second blast.
Oh, wait.
There's a control room.
Sorry.
There.
My dad loved playing this.
Is it?
If this is the map I think it is,
we're about to enter, like, an eight mech fight later on down here.
we're, like, on the second last mission then,
because that was his favorite one.
I am getting nervous.
Have I just remembered?
Oh, wait.
There's something I'm to destroy back there.
My apologies.
Sorry.
Oh, no.
I actually think this may be the second last mission.
Uh.
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, no.
I think it is.
No.
It's not sorry.
I think it should be done.
Am I even going to hit?
Nah.
It's going to go out of range, bro.
Oh, no.
If this is the one I think it is,
this is going to be a challenge.
If I was my dad's favorite map,
so surely that means I can do it.
My dad's favorite map.
I've all the standing spirit this time.
Oh.
I'm getting ready to get.
So, of course, it wouldn't do that.
Oh, no.
Games hate hate.
There's a special there.
I think the enemy.
Wow.
You're the only one that can shoot with that.
Oh, another make another make.
Oh, that's not.
I keep using that again.
But that's actually not what I'm supposed to do.
See these fucking me bam over the fucking tanks.
Oh, my God.
They like come out of nowhere.
And look at the situation.
Like I can't even.
I cannot avoid these attacks unless I get lucky like that.
Sorry.
I'm just using shotgun.
You know, don't hit me.
Don't hit me.
That's so rude.
Honestly, it is right there.
Members a smart sooner than expected.
I mean, if we do it, then yeah, I'll take a cup of tea.
I'll get some food, actually.
Because I don't want to eat.
We got him with their panty loons down.
That's right.
Getting that lava.
I think they can hurt themselves in the lava.
Unless it's only me because I'm classic video game.
Oh, that's okay.
There we go.
Well, the good news is you're super close to me.
The bad news is I'm overheating like no one's.
Oh, they might actually get me.
But sorry, I need to play safe.
Oh, for goodness sake.
He gets so close that I'm like getting cut cut.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Come on.
Get that one first.
Oh, maybe a double kill.
He got damaged so much from that mech blowing up.
Feels good, man.
He got damaged so much.
Okay.
Much mutual happy.
Mutual happy with how that occurred.
That came out so well.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
You ready?
How?
No, you're getting sprayed, bro.
You're getting sprayed just because of the...
Okay.
Okay, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Good work.
Let's free those villains.
Get out of here and find Ragnarok.
Calm down with you.
Marked and on radar.
Okay.
I think we're doing a good job.
Wow.
Good job, man.
That's always very satisfying getting a double whammy like that.
Right.
I'm like getting full up on like all this special stuff.
Full health.
I'm full on everything.
You know, I'm not until...
Wait, I need that one.
Hold on.
Sorry.
A little bit bigger than I anticipated.
It's too easy for such a gamer pro like me, honestly.
You can't, you can't hand...
Oh, I'm full on that.
Oh, that's the ammo type.
Sorry.
Is it this one?
Am I being a dum-dum?
Okay, I re-stocked eight more bullets, but that's okay.
It's the energy coil.
Is that why they're called?
Because you guys are such a nerd.
Oh, sorry.
This is the one.
Whoa.
You survived that?
I'm surprised.
Pleasantly surprised.
Not particularly surprised.
Wow, I wish that...
So this is the map I think is.
I'm nervous for what's up ahead,
but if it's my dad's favorite map,
then truly it can't be that bad, right?
Even though my dad was like pretty much number one on this game.
Incoming bombers.
Watch yourself.
What do they do?
Oh my god, they're literally fucking...
What, are they B-52s?
Jeez.
You coming back for more or not?
I hear a chopper now.
You're a chopper.
I don't like it.
I'm gonna do some of these from afar,
because there's a lot of noise ahead.
I don't think I'm gonna be doing myself
any favors just running in.
I'm gonna break that just in case.
I'll break this.
That's fine.
You're fine.
I think those are what communicate the hail attack.
I'm gonna try that.
Oh wow, hold on.
Man, I can't destroy everything all at once.
Give me a second.
Something.
I think I just hurt myself by accident.
I'm gonna build in.
Drat.
Drat, drat, drat.
That wasn't part of the plan.
Oh.
That hurt infantry.
Imagine being like, oh yeah,
by the way, your job is to go against an atlas.
An atlas?
Call me a deserter.
Freaking call me, I don't know.
What's the type of deserter?
Call me...
Wait, why can't I think of one deserter right now?
Call me chocolate pudding,
because I'm a deserter.
Get me out of here.
Sorry, that took me so long.
I don't know why that was so hard.
Watch out for what?
Oh, great.
I assume there's something special in here.
If it was behind a wee paywall,
I'd say that as if it wasn't just literally one thing.
A strawberry flan.
Ice cream.
A flan?
What's that?
Pancake or this?
Oh, sorry, I missed.
Yeah, that's what you wrote me.
Imagine surviving that back.
Cute.
Yeah, sorry.
I'm going to take every heal I get,
because I do not have enough health.
Ow.
Are you a deserter?
Because I terrimis-
terrimis-
you!
Hold on.
Oh.
I wonder if that does damage
if it hits me on the way down.
For goodness sake.
These tanks are absolutely calling me.
Bro, I can't even avoid them.
Is that geyser?
Is that water geyser to cool me down?
I'm not sure how much I cost it.
I don't want to stand on it
in case it's just a steam cloud.
I don't know.
You seem like water to me.
Oh, my God.
Sorry, I'm going to have to swap.
These guys are not taking the shotgun shells very well.
That's what I'm talking about.
Crap.
I'm taking some HP damage.
I don't think the game-
maybe the game does let you go all the way back
because your instant's in the map.
Like, it's one big map that's been unlocked.
Sir, to clear the way for the prisoners,
the turrets ahead need to be destroyed.
Yes, sir.
I've seen so many fixed defenses in one place.
Are they pointed the wrong way?
I don't know if they're fighting the wrong way.
They're seemingly pointed at me.
Oh, I can see it.
Okay, we got it.
Feels good, man.
Okay, there's a health.
Okay, I think I can see-
I was going to say I'm pretty sure that can see me.
Oh, no.
Thank you.
And another one.
Mech warrior, you should be able to see the camp
from where you are.
Yeah?
Sir, looks like a very light,
should be cake.
No, that is bait, if I've ever seen it.
I do not trust that at all.
There is one more thing over there.
Yep, there's another, another thing over there.
Wait, so what's that supposed to-
I can like-
Am I supposed to go all the way in a circle?
Like, around?
Please don't worry if you're-
Like, I cannot see what you're shooting at.
I promise you, I can hardly see either.
The crosshair is going red,
which means the AI is locked on,
so I'm just-
I am just taking it as it comey come comes.
Yeah, it's literally a trap.
I'm sorry, but-
There's only a light thing.
Yeah, I don't believe it.
Oh, I thought I should be able-
Take it easy, easy.
I'm even-
Yeah.
Okay, we made it down.
Nice and safe, nice and friendly.
There's no more turrets coming at us.
Um, we'll maybe take a few-
Oh, of course.
Oh, of course the HUD was telling us the truth.
Open the gates and defend the civilians.
Oh, yes.
I look very much like you.
I'm to defend civilians.
Why did that give me three?
Fuck.
Oh.
Atlas, okay.
Okay, where?
Where?
Right side, right side, right side on the HUD.
Scream down, scream down.
I have heavy ammo.
It's fine, it's fine.
We are over-keying, but we're just going to keep on at it.
Okay, we're just going to keep on at it.
Why is that Atlas got special moveset?
Okay, okay.
Cool down.
Let this-
Let this Atlas cool down.
We're going to go next.
We're going to pick up the health.
We're full health again.
Sir, watch yourself.
The drop ship's returning and it's hot-dropping another mech.
Uh-huh.
Please be another Atlas, because I can handle an Atlas.
I think it's a Ragnarok, considering how long this cutscene is going for.
No.
It's too Atlas-y!
Oh my god, when two Atlas do together, they become Atlas-y, like, uh, stuff.
Oh, oh lord, I do not like this.
And there's so many bunkers in my way.
Okay, that's why they gave me two health.
I'm going to slowly worm my way back to the two health bits,
as I destroy all the buildings in the way.
Sorry, my bad.
My bad, I'm just healing.
Okay, there are two health to my left now.
I feel okay.
I feel like we're melting this guy pretty adequately.
He is getting low.
And maybe we can get a double kill if he goes down and hurts him.
Oh, come on, hurt him.
Oh, shit, I did not need to take that one.
Okay.
Did he take any damage for that?
Oh, I don't think so.
Okay, we can't shoot each other over the wall.
He's, you're not shooting this.
Okay, now you are.
So, I can't shoot over the wall, but he can shoot over the wall.
Yeah, sounds a bit rude.
Have I got any extra?
No, I accidentally picked up both of them.
Oh.
Oh, he's limping.
Oh, I'm gone.
Look at the goods, though.
Eh, look at the goods, though, that drop from atlases.
Or atlasi.
Any atlasi, enjoy.
Hey, back.
A high-ranking, oh, sorry.
Prevent escape.
I think we're doing it.
Did I win the e-mech fight without realizing?
When you two atlasi come together to make a baby atlas.
Does this count now as three or is it more like a wasting?
I have no idea.
It was the repair yard.
We're on payback.
What's payback?
Is it like, this isn't the last mission.
I remember the look of the last mission.
Shawnee, they sat with extreme prejudice.
You know what you must do.
Random questions, you still want to hold it?
Naturally.
I can't believe that freaking got 50k views.
That's insane.
Honestly, I didn't expect that.
Shawnee taking on eight guys without breaking a sweat.
All I'm seeing is that recording booth.
The ASMR booth, sorry.
Payback, a high-ranking war of battlefields.
And one of the vehicles in the convoy.
Okay, this might require a few attempts.
I don't recall that magma gonna break and hurt me.
Don't be distracted.
Only one thing matters.
Watch school for it.
This convoy, this entire convoy.
Wait, I don't have enough HP for this.
Am I being silly?
Now you can have it up to you to fly into the lava.
That would be great.
They're all in catapult heavy mags.
To be sure you get the second to command,
you'll need to knock them all out.
Okay, so I'm to kill them.
First mag down.
Take up his health and then spray spray.
Uh, sure.
That's not even locking on.
Wait, I'm getting a blary is...
Hold on.
What are the tactics for this?
Is there tactics?
Is there really healing up here?
Huh?
I basically...
Well, I need to...
Oh, wow.
Holy crap.
The AI is, like, ready to lock on.
Oh, dear.
I think we're gonna need a strategy.
Oh!
I think this might be the strategy.
Uh...
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
We've got one.
Oh, there's health down there.
I don't want to get too greedy now.
I can let them pass.
Oh!
Did we do it?
By accident?
I think we did.
Okay, let's go get some health.
I think that would be the way to move right now
is to grab all these boobies.
Thank goodness I stopped, like, try hard on the target.
Right, let's catch up a bit.
He's a wee bit ahead.
Sir, the word of Blake is in full retreat.
Like amateurs, they've probably left something useful.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Hold on.
Is this fine?
Yeah, okay.
They do not have much health against an atlas like this.
Bro, just accept it.
You're getting wrecked.
Oh, there's something going for me at the left.
I don't know what it is.
It's not amazing.
Sirs, I'm reading multiple signatures.
It looks like another convoy.
Oh.
Foster, when you looked at the sensors the first time,
you missed a group of massive walking tanks.
Get a move on and stop that other group.
I love how cheeky they are to each other.
You missed a group of walking tanks?
I mean, honestly, she's pretty justified
for saying it like that.
Like, what do you mean you missed a group?
One of those mechs.
Keep after them, sir.
What?
There's so many enemies.
Is there supplies up here?
Is that why?
I think there may be supplies.
Let's see if we can get them.
Oh, of course they take these pretty much.
They're silly of me to assume other guys.
Okay, boom.
And then let's find all the good things in here.
Quite a few.
You, actually, I don't use rockets.
I think we're doing it.
I don't want to drink it, but I think we're doing it.
Okay, we've got full health.
That's B. Your target?
This is tamed.
You stop that right now.
You stop that.
You're trolling me.
It's not tamed.
Don't say such horrible things.
Oh, wait.
It must be supposed to be up or down right now.
I don't know.
Oh, fuck it.
It says go this way.
I'm going this way.
They're getting away.
Stop!
You're scaring me.
I'm in an atlas.
I'm so slow.
I can't even fly.
No, it's another get the convoy for the getaway mission.
Drat!
Right.
At least we know to destroy the bridge.
And then I'll pick up whatever they drop.
Okay, there is a fight.
That's what I want to hear.
That's exactly what I want to hear.
I actually want a fight
because I need my stuff a little bit.
Okay.
You're flying.
You get too close,
but I want to pick up the kiddies.
Okay, then we go next.
Next convoy.
Are they up there?
Oh, please tell me they're not up there.
Why would you do something to me like this?
How am I supposed to get off?
I'm not going back.
I haven't even unlocked Wild Card and Bind and Avis.
Like I'm like 99% sure
because I've never had, came across one yet.
I'll show you what my save file looks like
in the Bind and Avis.
You guys can be the judge.
That's why in November,
you guys are actually going to help me
fill the unlocks I need.
I think we might do one Eden run
on the Bind and Avis stream.
And then I want to play Lilith's read mode.
Some people absolutely despise read mode.
I actually quite like it.
I find it quite fun,
but only if it goes well, obviously.
Mercenaries, you will force me to abandon this world
and all it hides.
For that, you will face death.
Foster, can the Icarus get us off this rock yet?
No, sir.
Just local hops.
Captain, return to the Icarus.
We're going to-
Was this?
Oh, I almost lost.
This is the end of the map.
Holy crap.
Oh, my God.
Whoops.
I honestly don't mind read mode.
Who despised read mode is really hard.
Begin our best interest to capture whatever lost technology
is being evacuated with him.
Assault space port.
Someone has to go into a heavily guarded space port,
blow the Blake drop ship,
and kill or strand straighter.
Guess who gets the job?
Not it.
Right, you are a briefing boy.
Good luck, Captain.
Foster, your job.
You need to get the drop ship fixed
so we can get off this planet and enjoy our R&R,
after our esteemed captain gets done.
That has like a billion enemies in it.
As soon as you unlock the Atlas, Lilith,
it's not too, it's not too tricky.
Two more missions.
Oh, my God.
We're beating the game journalist.
Let's go.
Is the game sent me the wrong way?
No.
I'm being pranked.
Clearly.
You're blowing it right now.
Can I get across this one first, please?
Okay, now.
I saw my life flash before my eyes.
Oh, my God.
Is this another timed mission?
Yes or no?
That would have time to be fucking around
and destroying stuff.
Oh, they have full health.
Man, this game is short.
Older games tend to be like that,
although I think Conker's Bad Party
is the only game that was like old AF,
and it was like took so long to do.
I mean, I've never completed it.
I used to play the same mission as a child
and then get stuck at the exact same spot,
which honestly, that game was wildly inappropriate for me,
inappropriate for me to be playing as a child,
but hey, it gave me a personality,
so I can't actually say anything bad against it.
I'd actually be so boring if I didn't game.
I don't even think I would have anything to say to them.
I'd probably be like a mukbang type of person
and just watch people eat food all day.
I'd be like, oh yeah, this is time for it again.
You're so in my face.
No, no, okay, let's go again.
Oh, okay, let's go again.
Again, again, again, again, again, again.
That was my humble mistake.
I do apologize.
Literally went for a cheeky dip in the thing.
The only thing that can kill me is myself.
I am back to the video game.
Okay, I need to sprint across the bridge
because they're going to blow it up.
I cannot believe I just did that.
Into the flaming hot Cheetos.
Literally, what an air.
I can't believe I successfully managed that as hilarious.
I'm so energy-honored.
I don't know how I'm not in some e-sports team.
Is that good?
Not only am I terrible at the game.
Let's try that again.
This time, no perish.
I'm pretty cheeky.
Speaking, talking about hot sprang.
Yeah, Conqueror's had Inuit on it.
I, the childhood memory for me playing Conqueror's Bad Friday
is bouncing on that sunflowers.
Nothing else.
I used to do it for minutes at a time.
And then whenever I could hear my mom or dad come into the room,
I'd get off them because I'd be scared they'd be mad at me.
And they'd be like, what are you doing, strongy?
Right, do not fall.
Whoa, you idle.
They had a funny little ha-ha.
Oh, jeez.
Everything's got an HP up there.
You're not actually supposed to get stronger.
You should get weaker.
Right, do not fall off the map with time.
Even if the mix gets all the way in my face.
Oh my god, it's so fast compared to me.
I think, oh my god, such a fast mix.
Please stop.
Please, I beg you.
Give me a gun.
Yeah, I don't think going invisible at this stage
won't do anything for you, buddy.
Please do not drop your guns on them.
Is there anything else here?
Or is this just like a...
I am the great mate even.
Oh, is this a dead end?
OK, so I have to go that way.
Maybe we can get a few licks in though.
Yeah, we can.
Look at that.
That was a good lick.
Something, something red there.
Let's get it.
I love doing stuff from a distance.
I'd save some of our HP.
I hate the Dracula.
I never got to that stage as a child.
I unlocked the Sunflower,
and then I think after that I was just like,
I couldn't progress because I didn't know what was going on.
OK, there's a lava flume.
I guess I will love it.
I will allow a lava flume.
Just one, though.
There shall be no other lava flumming near me.
Oh, OK.
Well, that's illegal to do that.
Am I to destroy this?
Gain access to the spaceport.
OK, is it?
Aren't you at me?
Space...
I want to do a cheeky U-turn.
Cheeky U-turn moment.
Nah.
I hate when they get a lick on me when I'm...
The 80s, what do you mean?
Way too distracted by Sunflower Booba.
I did the pitchfork in Bunker's...
Bunker's Kites for...
Conqueror's Bad Ferdy.
I did the pitchfork inside the hay bale.
I did the Booba Sunflower,
and then after that I just kinda...
Like, I did the wasp.
I did the bull,
and then after the bull,
I think I got stuck in the bale.
I actually don't know how to progress,
so you guys don't have to hold my hand
when we get that game shot.
I don't know if we can get achievements for it,
because it's on rare replay,
but I don't know how the achievements work in that game.
Obviously, this is made before achievements really were a thing.
Entertuality.
Hold on.
I'm trying to, like, rotate between both...
Eh.
The missiles and the shotgun.
It seems to be very efficient,
which I'm quite happy with.
Take...
Woah!
Those are low keys!
They're so fucking skinny!
And, oh god, they have such high mobility.
This shouldn't be awful.
But they have low health.
That's my benefit.
They have low health.
I love when they just take it,
like a good little mech.
Honestly, you're such a good mech.
They double killed each other!
Oh my god.
I love when they take it, sorry,
but, like, literally,
this is the best feeling ever.
Two for one.
Yeah, their HP is literally so low.
Okay, blow up the tunnel.
Got it.
Or the bridge.
I don't know what one.
Then the bridge?
I just waste this one.
I know it doesn't do as much damage,
but I don't want to, like,
waste my good ammo on it.
If you like more old games,
and then good game,
good old games,
it's, like, for steam,
but some obscure stuff.
Mmm.
Their problem is I can only play games
that I've had experience before,
or seen be played,
which is why I play games like Mech Assault,
because I've seen my dad play it
like a million times over.
Oh, there's health there.
Oh, and there's a helicopter coming.
Oh, there.
Sorry.
I'm using the HUD,
and then looking at the same time,
which is the cause of me being there.
Oh, no.
Gee.
I just picked the health up.
Give me a second to do that.
And your dad's in school.
He plays mostly mobile games.
He tried to get into Starcraft for a bit.
He got in the floor,
so he doesn't game that much,
but we're going to play another game
called Halo Wars.
He was fucking addicted to that shit.
Holy crap.
He can get enough of it.
And the difficulty can increase,
and he got to a stupid, silly number
and difficulty,
which is honestly insane.
Oh, my God, Halo Wars.
Yeah, you guys have played Halo Wars, too.
I'm not going to lie, Reefland.
You'd get along with my dad very well.
He was addicted to it,
so we're definitely going to give Halo Wars a bash,
but it's quite long.
If I remember correctly,
it's a long game.
It's not like a...
I think it may even be a two-streamer.
Nope, I missed.
No!
I got him.
Uh...
Okay, there is a health spot.
I think...
I don't need it right now.
I'm actually still health.
I mean...
My dad has quite literally taught me
everything I needed to know about this game.
Okay, the doors are open.
Is this a fight?
If I've ever seen one,
it certainly looks like it.
I think we'll try and talk.
There's something going on over here.
I don't like it.
Is it a plan?
There's quite a few...
Oh, it's that building there.
Okay, I see it.
Hold on.
Let's get rid of it now.
We don't have problems.
Okay, that's what we want to see.
Take your time.
Time is on our side.
Health is on our side.
We don't need to be...
Going absolutely fast as far as I'm aware.
Unless maybe we do have enough.
Oh, there is.
We are over keeping quite nasty.
Did my dad ever try Warcraft?
I don't think so.
He tried Starcraft.
He got into a wee bit,
but I wasn't saying he went MLG crazy.
But he doesn't really game that much these days
because of his work,
but I'm hoping I can retire him next year.
So, obviously,
I've got quite a lot of motivational factors.
Like, the girls motivate me to work hard.
Like, my dad motivates me to work hard.
But like, in the nicest way,
like, if my dad wasn't cool with me gaming,
like, you guys tell me stories about your parents
kind of being a bit obtuse,
like, when you like, game or whatever.
If my dad wasn't like, cool enough to get into Xbox
and like, get online and all of that,
like, I wouldn't be a gamer.
I'd probably be like,
Ew, ew, makeup!
Ew, ew!
Oh, I love going out to nightclubs
and grinding on people.
Oh, like,
So, I do feel like, oh, my dad or whatever,
how it came up.
Like, my mom as well,
she never had any issues with gaming
because my dad's game,
so my mom was like, well, I don't,
I couldn't get to...
Oh?
Uh...
I don't remember that.
Okay.
Take it, take it, take it.
Yep, that's right.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Give him everything I got.
Come on.
Come on, buddy.
Parish.
That's all we'll see.
Right, you're next.
Okay, that's all I want to see.
That's all I want to see.
Come on.
Oh, look.
Yeah, if you have an invisible guy,
if you shoot,
he becomes less invisible in the multiplayer.
Whoa!
Not what we want to see.
Hold on.
Let's get rid of this building.
Not what we want to see.
We don't want him to respawn on enemies.
Come on.
There we go.
We don't want that.
Unfortunately, I'm very, uh...
Overkeating.
And these guys move left to right so quickly.
Oh, God, please hurt him.
Oh!
Oh, that's a...
I need to change that to my donal sound.
The sound of them exploding
is just like such a good sound effect.
Like, shaw.
That is so good.
Let's get rid of you.
Uh, looks like...
Oh, there we go.
Right.
Mama Dad gamed a bit,
but he stopped less the time going on.
Oh, my mom was like a Lara Croft e-girl.
She loves Lara Croft.
She loves the movies as well.
We should watch Lara Croft movies for my mom,
because I feel at home with it like I don't.
I need to do what again?
Shit!
I spoke over it.
The doors?
I don't know.
Oh, shit.
What am I to do?
Hello?
Then you make us all players a little bit of attention.
This?
Shit.
Doors can't be blown.
What, you calling yourself a door?
Calling yourself a challenge for me?
Am I being dumb?
Camera pan to the generators.
Find another way.
Okay, as long as we're not on a timed mission, right?
Haha, what if we're on a timed mission right now?
I was fucking around trying to look for...
Lara Croft and Joy are in a multiplayer mech assault smack talker.
When you guys are like,
uh, is your dad single?
Is your mom single?
No!
They're a gaming jewel!
And they have happy marriage.
And they have happy daughters.
And all is good in the world.
Oh, I see the generator.
I wonder if I, if I broke that before.
Would it have standard?
Is there a daughter single?
Do you want to meet my parents?
Would you be nervous if I brought them on stream?
Okay, now let's go fuck them up.
Bring my parents on stream.
Go to the...
We officially cannot hit on stories.
Do not hit on my mom and dad!
Honestly.
Do they want to be adopted?
Do you want to be my stepbrother?
Do you already know what kind of things I'm into?
Are you sure you want to be my stepbrother?
Yeah, I'll have you know what I created, I mean.
I don't think it happened.
Things would happen if you became my stepbrother.
Oh yeah, okay, okay.
All right, let's see what's going on.
Okay, the base doors just closed, which I don't like.
I'll bet that plane is loaded with goodness.
Destroy the drop ship or it can take off.
Well, considering you've locked me into a cut scene,
you know, it's really getting away, I have to admit.
It's really getting away.
Okay, I think that's it.
I didn't have much for it.
I'm like, hold on, there's an enemy.
Hold on, base.
Okay, hold on.
I think we're going to have to try hard a little bit.
Maybe we do a little bit of sweating.
Hold on, hold on, a little bit of sweating.
Just a wee bit.
Maybe, oh no, that's a terrible good one again.
Oh, and a clue.
I feel like he's so weak.
Oh, no, he's weak.
He's freaking glowing.
Wow, okay, that was good.
Bye.
Hot heals, I got the H.
There seems to be something up here.
Oh, hi there.
Whoa, the texture.
I don't know what it is.
I'm shooting at it anyway.
Definitely not having a lever.
Let's see if he can do the bit.
In the Disney music scene, I can do the bit.
Right, so this is just an end.
Okay, I am definitely not good at it.
What is going on over here?
I'd be nervous to meet my gran.
No, they shouldn't send love to you,
but I feel like she would be the protective one.
My gran's dead, so you don't have to worry about my gran?
Yeah, you don't need to worry about her approval.
She popped her cogs, so you're fine, Riflin.
Oh, that's funny as fuck.
Oh, honestly, it was just like, I'm like,
did I see it or did I just let it go?
I'm like, nah, that's actually kind of funny.
Oh, shit, here we go, here we go.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Nah, don't worry about it.
It's not as painful.
Oh, shit, I'm going to miss it.
There's the dropship.
Kill it.
Wait, what?
What you saw, straighter?
What?
Nah, it was like Solar's fuck to talk about it.
Mercenary scum, you'll die now.
You'll face Ragnarok.
What is that?
That's not in any of our technical readouts.
Oh, my God, it's the Ragnarok.
Oh, my God, that's right.
His ultimate is invincibility.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, oh, my God, oh, my God, oh, my God, oh, my God.
I completely forgot.
I forgot.
Holy shit.
I forgot everything.
Just send everything.
Call the guards.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, he's fucking annihilating me for another day.
Show mercy.
Show mercy, Modis.
Show me mercy, Modis.
Oh, my God, his ultimate is that freaking three rocket attack.
I know he's got technology.
We haven't.
See you in hell, strainer.
Sorry, sirs.
Couldn't help myself.
Well done, Captain.
At least now we know what Ragnarok is, or it was.
Sir, too bad we couldn't capture it and analyze it.
Sir, what?
Look at the feet from the cameras.
Whoa, they had two?
Foster, send in the tech.
Oh, I thought I had to do a double fight there.
I was getting scared.
We need to stop the Stoom's Day device
and save this world.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, my God.
I thought we were going to have to do a second fight.
I was like, I'm wasting 50% health.
Ready to roll.
Oh, man, all of us are depending on you.
Got anything to add, Foster?
Drinks on me when you get back?
Good man.
OK, Ragnarok.
The Ragnarok is a unique prototype
built using Loth Tech to provide massive stopping power.
Wow.
Look at that swagger.
OK, let's see what we're dealing with.
OK, we've got sniper bullets, rockets.
Wait, and then...
Wait, then how do I get big...
How do I do the...
Wait, how do I do that?
Do that again.
What's the red?
I don't know what the red is.
But I didn't like it.
Have I had to secret Abeliae in all these mix
that haven't used before?
It's down on its arse.
Yeah.
Hold on.
OK, what the fuck?
Oh, OK.
Of course.
OK, let's see what we're dealing with.
Why would we...
All right, let's destroy that.
Holy shit.
I forget I have nothing to level with.
I'm not getting hit.
Now, I don't have as much health as the Atlas.
It's not letting me select that one.
Red is how long it takes to wield it.
I don't know if you know it or working with people.
Quick.
I'm fucking trying, hen.
Oh, my God, he's already on fire.
It's fantastic.
Wow.
Oh, it's...
I'm going to sneeze.
It's so lovely.
It brings a tear to me.
Oh, how fucking easy it is with a regular ult.
OK, let's get right into this.
Wow, you can't do that to me.
That wasn't very nice.
Oh, this is a fuck up.
OK, get fucked.
Great, you fuck off.
Holy shit.
Yeah, I definitely do not have as much health.
Can you...
As if there's a wee bam up there shooting me as well.
Hold on.
Yeah, yeah.
Take that, bitch.
Hold on.
Inbop.
Sorry, I'm trying so hard.
I would actually love to do this in one.
Because the only time I totally lost
was that crazy runaway mission,
which you had to have known the layout
to even know what to do.
And I jumped off the map like a dafty.
OK, that's fine.
Ooh.
Oh, this is what I remember my dad doing all the time.
I think it was me.
Hold on.
I'll just fuck him up.
Look at the thing in the background.
I'd really rather not have infinitely spawning enemies.
I don't know about you guys,
but infinite spawning enemies is not my sound of fun.
My sound of fun?
Gee, I can hardly speak and play at the same time.
I'm so sorry.
I think my dad used to perfectly not destroy the buildings
so he could collect all these items and leave them there.
I'm actually sorry.
I'm legit calling him after my aim is done.
Because I need to know.
I think it's true.
Oh, come on.
I got you.
Bear in square.
Oh, shit.
I'm low health.
Hold on.
I'm getting my dad on the phone right now.
He fucking walks me through this damn game.
Hold on.
There must be like...
Oh, come on.
Not another one.
OK, I'll just talk about that.
Where are these freaking supply bases?
Hold on.
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, no.
Why did the fillet go up?
I don't know why it is up.
Right, I just tried that one last week.
Are you?
No, he's not.
It's not reloaded yet.
Can I get you first?
Whoa, I need to start doing that whole crap.
Please.
Aim.
I'm begging you.
Why aren't you freaking going off?
Yeah.
Oh, come on.
Freak.
Please, I'm on my knees.
I was far too early on that.
That's fine.
I can pick up the goods.
Wah.
OK, here we go.
Here we go.
Where is he?
Oh, fuck, I missed him.
I don't know where the fuck he was.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, he's limping.
That's what we want to see.
Oh, thank goodness.
Crap.
I'm starting to feel the struggle.
I'm not sure how much confidence I've got.
I'm going to be honest.
I'm getting a bit nervous.
I'm getting a little shaky.
I'm getting nervous.
I'm going to grab this little guy over here.
Hail's bar.
I know.
Right, I can't grab that.
I got this.
Are these even possible?
I just destroyed my health bar for that.
Crap.
OK, OK, it's fine.
It's fine.
OK, I need to use my ultimate.
Holy crap.
It like respawns so quickly as well.
I'm still going to get to see you there.
Hold on.
OK, use my ultimate.
Wham.
It's ultraviolet.
Whoa.
Please do not glitch out on the last mission.
I appreciate that.
Hold on.
I'm going to dream far.
Sir, Atlas inbound.
OK, OK, I can handle it.
Atlas is gone.
Let me just get the other things that are kind of
to plant me up with this.
Oh, here he comes.
Right, ultimate, ultimate.
OK.
Uh, how often?
Am I just kind of the mercenary?
I have a prolonged escape
to real life.
I am.
I'm happy to be the mercenary.
Hmm.
I don't like that.
OK, ultimate's ready.
Please.
OK, yay.
We hit nothing.
Let's go.
I love hitting nothing.
OK, he's on fire.
He's on fire.
I'm also in trouble equally, though.
Please drop pieces of health I beg of you.
Whoa, those rocks are also falling.
Let's destroy a few buildings while we're at it.
Yeah, I'm going to need the ability to see if there's going
to be more enemies about to spawn in.
I'm going to need the ability to see if this thing's
going to be great instead of, like, playing hide and go seek.
Zero aim assist on the health fire.
Yeah.
It's the field of view in this game is absolute.
Hey, it's all shadows.
I'm going to be fighting shadows right now.
Give me that.
As if I missed 20.
Hold on.
All right.
Let's hope there's some health on the route
because I'm sparking a little bit.
My little ankles are sparking.
It's just not a good sign at all.
You need to traverse these lava fields to get to the drill.
Yes, that's fine.
Who's that?
Oh, it's a mech.
OK, well, that was completely overheated for that,
not to get a look in.
Oh, god, there's two of them.
Sorry.
All you're going to hear in this is, um,
because I'm literally just spamming the button to activate it.
I'm so sorry.
I mean, it's working.
Oh, is he in the lava?
If you're right in front of me,
you're getting ultimated right now.
Oh, hey, that didn't quite work in the end, so that's OK.
Come on.
I'm so heavy.
I'm so hot.
The mech is like running on fire.
Bro, you aren't going to give up.
We'll get two health back from those two,
which should take me back to full health.
Oh, just under full health.
He's not going to lie.
I think that's how you're supposed to play this mech.
Just constantly.
Oh, wait, the lava plume.
I'm supposed to walk through the lava plume.
Is it possible to do it as little damage as possible?
OK, hold on.
Oh, no.
Oh, shit.
What have I done?
OK, OK, OK, it's fine.
It takes a hot second for it to actually register you're in lava,
which I'm quite glad about.
Wah, OK, that was a bit silly of me,
but we did it.
We did it.
We're fine.
Kind of.
OK, big one.
It might take a little bit of damage.
We better, we better, we better, we better.
Could have been worse.
OK.
OK, ultimate time, I guess.
Oh, completely missed.
No, I hit.
Wah, I hit, I hit, I hit.
Now, if this mech could just calm down a bit.
Whenever I hear something aiming at me.
The gate ahead will take you to the drill approach.
Hurry.
I see him.
Oh, there's fucking Atlas as well.
Oh, shit.
Shit, shit, shit.
Do not like this.
Hold on.
I need to pick them off.
Oh, my God, I need to pick them off.
OK, Atlas has really low mobility,
which I'm going to use my damage.
One is taken down.
Maybe the Atlas can take some fucking damage.
OK, he's limping.
That's what I want to see.
I want to see you limping, darling.
No, you want to limp for me, don't you?
Oh, yeah.
OK.
And then, ultimate.
And then, receive.
I'm going to spam you down until you're nothing.
OK, perfect.
Perfect.
I don't know if I can grab that.
I may be able to grab that with my invincibility shield.
Holy crap.
I think we're doing it.
I don't know what mission we're on.
I don't know if we're at the end of the game or not,
but I think we're doing it.
OK, perfect.
Perfect, perfect, perfect, perfect, perfect, perfect.
Perfect.
Stony, leave me limping for real.
These fights are getting kind of heated.
Look, the map's covered in lava.
I'm overheating as a mech.
It's not a bad joke if you put two and two together.
Jeez.
These guys are terrible.
Whoa.
Next section.
Ready to rock number two.
Oh.
Sir, the trail isn't far down this path.
I am leading a number of large mechs defending it.
I wonder if they even know what they're guarding.
Captain, good luck.
We're depending on you.
Yeah, you keep saying the whole world is depending on my shoulders.
That's quite a lot.
I'm not going to lie.
Like, you know, not a lot gets to me,
but saying that the whole world depends on me,
like right now, right at this very second.
Yeah.
Sorry, I was just checking if there's like any secret behind me.
Stony, you always huggy here.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Right.
OK, wait.
If they've given me eight minutes,
this round can be done in four.
I am OK.
Holy shit.
I'm getting obliterated.
I'm not the good thing.
Like, actually obliterated.
I've not even started.
Oh, my God.
And I'm so slow to turn around.
Oh, I got him though.
OK, I got him though.
I got him though.
Oh, my God.
Right.
It only takes four minutes to finish this mission.
That's how it works.
It's four minutes.
That's all.
And I'm already over here.
That's safe.
Oh.
What am I supposed to do?
I don't know.
For a man.
Four minutes.
And I can't even get around the corner.
I'm already lost the frickin' minute.
Please.
Video game work with me here.
Yeah, that's right.
You better be.
Yeah, you better give me real quick.
I don't know if I'm fucking good.
I'm sorry for grabbing this stuff.
But if they gave me eight minutes,
that means I have four minutes to fuck all the show.
Are we already here?
Or did I have eight minutes to come here?
Whoa.
You perished.
Am I supposed to perish you?
I feel like it.
Uh, what?
I just wasted everything on that ship.
And that wasn't even my target.
Please, Atlas.
Not now.
Please.
Surely.
Oh, I've actually fucked that
because I went for that ship.
And it wasn't even my target.
It wasn't my target.
I've actually pulled that up so badly.
Okay.
We'll need to restart because I messed that up.
But that's okay.
Oh.
Hello.
Oh, because I aimed at that ship.
I got annihilated.
Holy.
Hmm.
Holy moly.
Okay.
Yes.
I understand.
The drill isn't far down this path.
Okay.
Right.
Let's go to the choppers first.
We know there's choppers ahead.
Okay.
Here they come.
I don't really understand what I'm supposed to do.
I'm going to be honest.
It's tough to rule.
Hold on.
Holy moly.
I'm wondering because of the environment as well.
Oops.
Sorry.
Oh, and I just damaged myself.
Lucky me.
Um, because obviously I'm just so good at that.
Uh, it's actually my best winning strategy in this game.
Let's see if my snipe is better than this one.
Tanks are going to come around the corner.
Okay.
We already know that.
Oh, one's down already.
Okay.
We're doing a much better run already.
I need to keep using my ultimates.
Give me full health.
Do not shoot at the ship.
The ship is not the objective.
Shabby and harem.
What the heck?
I was about to redirect it to you.
Don't be selfish, Shabby.
Get back online.
Right.
Okay.
Take a breather.
Let's go.
Okay.
Atlas is on fire.
I repeat.
That's what we want to see.
Atlas down first.
Atlas is the biggest issue.
Hi, harem.
We're playing mech assault.
It's not the easiest game.
It's a very old game.
Very much an older game.
I am doing absolutely dog ass right now.
Holy crap.
I'm messing this up so badly.
Right.
Got one.
We've got one.
That's all we need.
My Ragnarok flame is a fact.
That's fine.
The second Atlas is now fucking up my ass.
I'm not the good way.
I am using my ultimate so much.
I really am.
I'm trying my best.
I am darling.
So I'm trying my best.
Hi, harem.
Hi, Shabby.
What was the...
On the agendination for the stream today for sheepsters?
Actually, there's underwear.
What one it could be.
Oh, forgive me for sake.
I'm going to get a couple ammo.
I'm going to need to pick this up.
This fucking Atlas with his real gun
is going for my cooter.
And not the good way.
Okay.
Let's get rid of him.
Whoa.
That's not Atlas.
It's a different floor.
Right.
Get you.
Can you take some damage?
That would be great if you could have taken some...
Like, honestly, don't be so selfish.
Take some freaking damage.
Hold on.
Oh, please hit.
Please hit.
Okay.
We've got two hits.
We've got two hits from our ultimate.
I'll take it.
He's on fire.
That's all I need to see.
No.
Sorry, mate.
I'm getting more and more.
Fuck you.
Get right.
He's limping.
Oh, yeah.
I'm going to pick up the stuff that dropped over here.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Hold on.
There's like a few things on the map.
There's a few things on the map.
Hold on.
Give me a second.
You guys need to relax.
Relax.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
What's the problem?
I'm just trying to destroy everything.
Sheesh.
You guys don't have any fun.
Are they infinitely respawned?
Or am I misappropriated?
Holy crap.
Are these guys infinite respawned?
She's falling for the bait.
Here's the drill.
The grunt spam is probably to waste time.
Fuck you, old bitch.
Fuck you, bitch.
Fuck you, booty.
Am I supposed to sacrifice myself?
I actually don't remember how this game ends.
Uh, I'll listen.
Self-destruct.
You must confirm triggering the self-destruct sequence
in order to blow up the drill.
Press the A button to self-destruct.
Am I going to get a cutscene?
That was so chaotic.
Okay, I sacrifice myself.
Okay.
Wait, we save all of humanity in the door.
You can get this.
Wait, did that survive?
The drilling device is going critical.
Keep in it.
Any chance our boy made it?
Unknown.
There's a secret escape pod?
Hey, Tiger, you're finally awake.
Oh, right.
So Lieutenant Foster and the Tex
have been looking at your little toy.
We thought you were taking the dirt nap for sure.
Nice trick.
Sirs?
Your cockpit carried you out of that inferno
and straight back to our loving arms.
Sirs?
You really need to see this.
Oh, no.
This is technology that we have never seen.
And this is just the start.
We're not sure yet what all it can do,
but it saved your life.
I wonder if the enemy...
We handed it to the word,
saved everyone's butt,
and in the process definitely got the prize.
The other Dragoons are still down there
mopping up the remaining fanatics.
Most of them started running after you,
86, their commander.
We beat them on this planet,
but I have a feeling this war is just beginning.
The problem is a lot of them got away
and they'll spread like a virus.
So congratulations.
We've earned our pay
and a permanent place
on the word of Blake to the list.
Yay, the framerate's fucking dying.
They'll be coming for us.
And I'm damned if I'm going to give them your toy back.
Question is, are you ready for this sport?
Sure.
I'm ready.
We did it.
And the video game journalist lied.
This game...
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
My Xbox's dust issue.
Oh, my God.
What the heck just happened?
Jeez, Louise.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
The dust is really building up.
Holy crap.
We actually did it.
I'm so surprised.
I better just play that game.
Hi.
Hi, I'm Strawny.
I don't even have a chat in slide.
Hold on.
Nope.
That's just...
That's just my...
Where the heck am I supposed to be on this?
This?
Oh, I'm hiding.
Oh, okay.
Hi.
Oh, let me turn off reactive model.
We did it.
I said, let me...
Is that reactive model?
Is that how bright I normally am?
Jeez, that's so bright.
Hi.
Hi, Hirom.
Thank you for joining.
And thank you, Sheepsters,
for redirecting into me.
Wait, are you straining?
The cold fish?
Heck, yeah.
I don't know if you can hear my little background music
should be in right now.
But we freaking did it.
I didn't realize Sheepy was gonna finish,
to be honest.
I was gonna redirect into her,
but I don't know if anyone else was coming on.
Where is it?
Is there anyone alive at all?
Will you play the second game?
I didn't even know there was a second game.
Oh, Mamosa.
Yes, okay.
I can happily redirect into Mosa.
Right.
Just so you know,
I'm going to do my membership ASMR stream early,
because I genuinely thought it was gonna take
like a couple billion hours to do this.
And every single Veloer model has so much detail.
I don't even think the girls know this.
Oh, well, I spent a pretty penny.
Yeah, but we're like,
your models look like shit.
And it's like, try again.
Good luck with that, mate.
Good luck.
Like, I'm sorry,
but we got designed out the wazoo.
And starting remember,
you have a bedroom scene.
I forget.
Oh, somewhere.
Yeah, I'll set up for the ASMR.
Um, I didn't know Mekosal even had a second game.
I don't even think my dad played it.
Hold on a minute.
Your phone, I'm gonna be like,
dad, do you recommend the Mekosal 2 game?
And he'll be like, why, Strony?
And I'll be like, I may or may not have played it on stream,
the first one anyway.
Um, oh, I didn't know.
It has spectacular lighting.
Yeah, oh, your phone.
And the start in street.
Oh, you guys haven't even seen my singers.
I don't even have my singers that are like activated.
I don't even use it.
The dad, and dad will watch the whole vlog.
Honestly, he'll start giggling if I send him the link to that.
Um, but he's busy with work,
which is why I'm trying to get him retired,
because I don't want him to like work himself
until a heart attack or something like that.
Does dad play anything?
Um, I would say no.
However, when he comes over,
I'm gonna download Halo Wars for him,
and he can play Mekosal.
I'll keep this installed if he wants to play it.
Um, dad gaming channel when?
Are you more interested in my dad gaming than me?
Strontium Games.
Call the channel Strontium Plays Games or something like that.
Quick, donate to the dad retirement fund.
No, no, no, no.
Let me earn it.
Let me work for it.
Let me upload ASMR.
Let me do an exchange for goods and money.
Let me do that, okay?
Hey, you should do Halo Co-op.
I think we will.
I'm like, I don't know how much patience
and how long he'll play it for,
and the problem is if I ask him questions during the game,
he's probably gonna be like,
Shawnee, shut the fuck up and try to play the game.
He'll probably be like,
wait, you talk and play through the game the entire time.
I'm like, yeah, that's how it works when you stream.
You can either talk to chat
and like respond to what they're saying.
You can commentate the game.
You can go on a tangent and that kind of thing.
But he'll be like, look, I'm here trying
to like defeat the covenant, like shut up, Shawnee.
And I'll be like, okay, thanks, dad.
Okay, I'll try my best.
That's my only thing if I did try and do Co-op with my dad.
But maybe I could record it
and like put it into like a funny highlight video instead.
Because I was gonna do like my dad guesses VTuber names
or my dad renames VTubers for the heck of it.
Cause if you thought Fondle of Boozom was bad,
my dad's gonna start naming VTubers like after Celtic players
and be like, oh, that's Nakamura.
Oh, that's, is it John Elton was the manager?
Someone called John dad and dad, dad names Jen too.
Honestly, that'd be funny.
He plays the game.
I commentate over it.
Oh, possibly that would work out.
Um, would he call Azura tits McGee?
Oh, absolutely.
He, my dad is like absolutely hilarious.
Like one time we went into the Co-op together
and they sell these like frog cakes and he gasped
and he went, oh, Shawnee, it's Peppy.
Like Peppy the frog.
Is it true your dad is a fucking slime VTuber?
No, Shawnee on stream would have 30 second delays
so that Shawnee can censor it.
Oh, honestly, I'm like, my name is Shawnee.
Shawnee is not helping chat when he's being on stream.
My mom.
But yes, John Elton right now.
The manager that used to be for Celtic.
Oh, Jock Steen.
Sorry, not John Elton.
I don't, as Jock Steen was a previous manager at Celtic.
We need him to operate a Cyclist VTuber.
I think he'd rather stab himself in the Cyclops eye
than become a Cyclops VTuber.
Peppy the frog is my religion.
My favorite animal is Peppy the frog.
Ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, yes, yes.
I bet your dad would like a slime.
You know what?
I'll ask him.
I'll, when, when he gets here,
I'll show him a picture of the gen two concepts
and I'll stick a slime girl in between one of them
and I'll get him to rate them one out of 10.
And I bet you he'll agree with me and I'll be like, that looks,
he'll be like, that looks like piss but colored blue.
That's what he's gonna say.
He's gonna forget Shawnee the second, the stream blue.
I know that's why we're not, we're not doing live.
No chance.
Shawnee and dad ain't, ain't coming live.
If he says yes to slime, there has to be one.
Okay, I'll make you a deal.
If the slime girl outranks any veal or concept that we have,
I will give someone a slime toggle.
How about that?
You can tell she be chatting here with the slime girl propaganda.
Honestly, your propaganda is useless.
Not all slime girls are blue.
What, you want, oh, so you don't even want
the traditional blue slime girl.
It has to be an alternative color of slime girl on top.
Wow, I see your priorities.
I see your priorities.
Shocking behavior.
Shocking, honestly.
Paint, purple.
You want a purple slime girl?
No.
Shawnee is immune to boob again though.
Shimmering orange.
What, so she's fucking neon pea color.
Orange, tangerine slime girl.
I'll call her, I'll call her tango
because she's tangerine.
Why not?
White slime girl, all right, you're done.
You're done, mods, get that man.
Jump on, jump on mods.
Slime girl is the lowest tier.
It's like McDonald's of slime girls.
I have to admit, I agree with that sentiment.
I agree, I agree.
Nuclear yellow, white jar slime girl.
You're done, you're getting timed out as well, right?
You're all getting timed out.
If your pea is orange, you need to go to a doctor.
Are you squirming me right now?
I swear if you're asking for slime.
I'll take that BT.
Yeah, good luck.
Thank you for the tip, Rilke Cadmus.
You take that bit because I know for a fact
my dad couldn't give less of a,
about slime girls.
He, in a lineup of Gen 1's designs,
I already know he's gonna like she be the most
because they, because they're blonde.
I do know her, her chest is out.
It'll be she be he likes first, then Azura,
then Mercy, then Icey, then Amylast.
I can already tell.
He's gonna be scared of the lollipops
because he doesn't consume anime.
If you don't consume anime or like any of that content,
it can be a bit startling seeing lollipops.
ASMR, Amy turns Strony into a slime girl.
I believe her.
Honestly.
Yeah, my, this man likes them big.
Yeah, he's definitely like,
he's not gonna be interested in,
I am not getting my dad to rate my beach ever model.
That seems a bit, other than like, I'll tell,
like he already knows that I'm Strony,
like after and such thing.
Understood, but we are in anime world.
Lollipop covered slime girl.
You know what?
If I look back and chat one more time
and see the S word,
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going scorched earth.
I'm going nuclear.
Do I make myself clear?
So I'm not looking at chat right now.
I'm getting ready to redirect into mimosa
because she's about to reach the watch time.
So please do consider watching her.
I am going to take a five minute break
and then we are going to boot up.
I like them.
Scorched earth.
Scorched earth is a saying where,
you know what?
We're in the information age.
Scorched earth meaning, let's search it.
Scorched earth.
Used to describe a military policy
in which all houses, crops, factories
in the area are destroyed
so that the enemy cannot utilize them.
And in layman's terms,
scorched earth means that you're all in trouble
if I read slime one more time.
I don't know why you guys are like so interested in slime.
It's not.
Why are you, why?
Why?
It's not going to work in each of her.
Yeah, that's scorched.
What's scratched?
Oh, did I say it wrong?
Did I say scratched earth?
Scratch my arse earth.
I'll scratch the earth's arse.
Stronium will burn viola to the ground
before having a slime grow.
Now, if one of the girls wants a slime toggle,
sure, knock yourself out just to upset me.
I don't care if they want that.
They can get it.
They want it.
They could get it.
I'm not stopping them from any goals like that.
But if you are asking me for a straight up slime girl,
default outfit, default position, no, I don't care.
I don't care.
So any muscle mummy concepts, that's called leaks.
I'm not allowed to leak that yet.
All I can say is that there's been progress
behind the scenes.
That's all I can say.
I'm not saying nothing more.
Everything's under NDA.
No, there's no NDA.
Everything's under NDA though, but there's no NDA.
I can't be also NDA.
I fucking can't stand them.
An elemental girl, like a flaming raccoon and that.
You know what's funny?
I sent away a spring in Skyrim,
and I did not get back a spring in Skyrim at all.
But I sent it away.
So I tried my best.
You are the NDA.
I'm an NDA's worst nightmare.
I am literally loose lip sync ships.
I cannot shut the fuck up about all my interests.
We've got the first animation back
for the alternative video game, and it looks good.
It looks good.
I just don't know how long it's going to take.
I still want to say July, end of July.
If not very early August, incredibly early August,
there's no way it's going past halfway through August.
We're just waiting on the animations,
and then everything,
all the puzzle pieces can be put together
once the animations are finalized.
I saw a preview of Icy's animation,
and you're welcome.
I saw I'm going to say you're welcome.
We only bring up some stuff to tease.
Yeah, I know you teasing.
I wanted to make a joke about our lips,
but the Japanese one wins.
I know.
You need to be quick.
You need to be quick,
if you want to make a joke on something I said,
because I'll be off it real quick.
As the human race has proven,
anything can be at this point.
You want us quick?
Are you kidding me right now?
I swear if this is a slime girl.
Strongly, if you're up for a scary game,
a few days ago a game called Still Wakes the Deep came out.
It takes place on a Scottish oil rig and has a great story.
Oh, does it?
Is it?
Oh, I need to get a heart rate monitor.
I don't.
Hold on.
Let me put it in my notes right now.
Like right this moment.
Hold on.
Let me write my notes.
Write my notes.
Heart rate monitor because I need it,
and then I need a new shot caller,
or actually hold on.
Sin sister, shot caller, cold smile.
Her problem now, not mine.
Yes, I might give it a shot.
Also, actually Scottish voice actors,
not Americans try to be Scottish.
Oh, praise the fucking Lord.
It's not that hard to find Scottish actors.
It's that thing like Junkrat and Overwatch as an American,
and it was like, oh, come on.
You're telling me there wasn't one voice actor available
that could do Maniac Australian?
Yeah, I find that hard to believe.
Mentioning the heart rate monitor,
did you get the burner phone?
No, I'm going to ask Sin sister
if I could just use her phone number.
Yeah, oh, well, yeah.
Okay, well, we both just answered each other's question there.
He's getting the feeling for having a shield generator.
Is the Australian guy from Siege voice finals?
I have no idea.
Name two Scottish voice actors.
Strony Cuttles and Sin sister.
Thank you.
I'll be here all day.
Anyone else?
I promise you it's not that hard to find actual a Scottish.
Well, actually, Sin sister doesn't count
because she's not.
She's honorary Scott.
You know what I mean?
Okay, look, you know what I mean?
No, Sin isn't Scottish.
You thought I was Welsh?
What the fuck?
Are you trolling?
You did not think I was Welsh.
Isn't Welsh like,
I'm the only gay in the village that's Welsh?
No. Sin is honorary Scott,
which not actually is not.
No one can do a good fake Scott accent.
It's like there is no Welsh and Strony now.
Someone thought you were Welsh or anything.
Oh my God, Sheep Girl, Gen 2 confirmed.
And then POV, you're supposed to be a Sheep Shagger.
Oh, that's awful.
I'm sorry for even saying that.
It's funny in the moment,
but now that I've said it out loud.
Oh, thank you for the tip anonymous as well.
But yes, I'll definitely,
once the heart rate monitor comes through,
I will be messing around.
I want to do that fitness Nintendo game Ring Fit,
but again, I need a heart rate monitor
to show you how quickly my heart is about to explode
because I'm needing to get some exercise in
and because I'm streaming all along,
I'm not really getting that exercise.
I'm being a naughty girl.
I'm not getting that exercise.
I'm going to do it with you.
But yes, I'm going to be doing that.
No, I've got my first limited ad stream.
No, this cannot.
No, what?
I've got, no.
More things have been hit with limited ads.
No way.
My freaking, my RuneScape stream.
My RuneScape stream where I got Wrecked and Connect 4
got hit with limited ads.
Don't you dare, YouTube.
Stop it, YouTube.
You're so stinky.
Okay, but all my other stuff is fine.
Literally the RuneScape is probably because of the tinfoil.
We spoke too much about BlackRock.
They got me.
I can't believe it.
They're killing my income source.
Right, I just,
I'm going to redirect into mimosa in a second.
I do want to say tomorrow,
if I'm not mistaken, is Valtral, okay?
But hear me out.
It is two hours after my usual stream start time.
Okay?
It's going to be a shorter stream
so I can focus on some ASMR work as I always do.
In Valtral, oh, sorry.
Ballatral or Valtral.
It starts two hours later
because Veeler having a meet-in.
I need to make sure the girls are all good and even fine.
Catch them up with them
because I really had a chance to talk to them all.
Obviously, Emma doesn't count
because she's not even at her PC.
She's not even in the company.
But yeah, we're going to have a nice little girl group meeting
and the best time zone for it was my start time
because American, Europe, mashed together.
And what do you get? A pancake.
So I'm going to be two hours.
No, I'm not going to be late.
The stream is two hours later.
So just keep that in mind for Valtral.
The stream is two hours later than usual
just because I'm catching up with my girls,
making sure everything's okay
and everyone's having a good time.
Because it's all fine and well,
like sending a message or a DM and being like,
oh, are you good?
But when you hear someone in voice chat,
they can bring up concerns
or they can bring up things they maybe hoped
would be better or have gone better.
So yeah, too early.
I don't really think it's going to be that long
unless we girls can.
You know what happens when girls get together?
Can't shut the fuck up.
But yeah, two hours extra sleep.
Nice.
Yeah, it's literally for the folk
who are like absolutely exhausted.
You get two extra hours.
God, my French tip nails are growing.
The fuck is actually getting pretty gross now.
I'll have to admit, yeah.
Yapping intensifies.
Yeah, basically it's just going to be a big old yap fest
and I'll be like, I hope you guys are okay.
And everyone will be like, yeah, you're okay.
And I completely forgot to do that 5K celebration
because everyone hit 5K.
So I'm going to see if I can get the social media manager
to post the artwork I got for it as a celebration.
I cannot wait for you guys to see the 10K celebration
on everyone.
I got a really good artwork.
Sorry, but it's like that.
It's a beautiful 10K artwork.
You VLU girls are running your purr fans' ragged.
Are you drained like that one meme?
Don't mention it.
How's your heart doing?
A lot better.
It's still like blood underneath the skin.
That's what it is at the moment.
A video or a picture.
An artwork.
I got a special artwork for 10K,000 subscribers.
For like, when everyone reaches 10,000 subscribers,
it will go live and it's a beautiful piece of artwork.
I absolutely adore it.
I think we might try and work on free access rewards at Milestones.
So you know how I'm kind of doing one ASMR video per 1,000 subscribers?
I obviously am in a bit of a deficit and need to start uploading them.
But I will.
I'm getting on it.
I promise I'm getting on it.
I am going to see if the girls might consider doing,
even if it's like a voice pack, for example,
or like a thank you audio on the alternative account,
something like that when they reach Milestones,
just to make things like a bit sweeter,
like any support you are clipping or tweeting or retweeting,
or you know, any support like that.
It just, it feels a bit sweeter and that you are getting rewarded for it.
I think the problem is more YouTube you already made.
I definitely did make the 2K one,
but I'll go back to the drawing board.
It's not a problem.
I'm going to do a tapping one with my fake nails,
because fake nails sound awesome when it comes to tapping anymore.
And strong.
Your feet are still hot listening.
Oh, don't.
Oh, don't say it like that.
Don't say it like that.
And I'm basically that Mexican alien.
And but yes, I am going to let you guys get redirected into mimosa.
Please do consider hanging about for a couple of cheeky minutes or so,
because she is very close to being monetized.
She just needs to watch ours.
So she's pushing herself for an endurance stream,
which has made her a perfect target for my Borderlands 2 gameplay that I want to sort out.
I want to see if I maybe get it done in July.
Mimosa seems like a good candidate.
I'm wondering if I could grab an endurance stream from VNU,
and then an endurance streamer from Mythos.
And then it could be like a really cool four way like get to know each other.
There's been fucking VTubers are so nice to me, by the way.
Holy shit.
I've got another ASMR collab on the way.
Turns out VTubers like are so kind and give you the time of day.
Like I redirected into AcoNono.
Did you see her little fucking call saying it was so good?
I don't know.
Sorry, not AcoNono.
With the bouquets.
And she was like, I think Strongie is a cult fish and stuff.
And then she followed me on Twitter and I'm like,
Gee, Willy, Curse, you've got me blushing now.
Stop it.
But yeah, VTubers are so fucking nice.
Sorry, I don't care where anyone says.
I'll defend VTubers.
Yeah, alias.
Literally VTubers are so nice.
I said it.
They're nice.
Everyone seems so nice to me.
What the fuck?
They're not like, oh sorry, that was my controller.
They're not like, oh you whore.
I don't want to interact with you.
They're like, oh my god, it's you.
Yeah, I'd love to do an ASMR collab.
And I'm like, oh, it's so freaking cute.
The yes chant.
Yeah, it's for him.
We love VTubers around these parts.
Let's go.
Yes.
Okay.
I am going to go offline and give me 15 minutes.
I'm going to get some food down my gullet
and I'm going to get a cup of tea
and then I'll come back for a membership ASMR stream again
where we can just babble away to each other.
If you an alias collab.
Oh, I've not even, I've not, it wasn't alias.
I was actually someone else who I've never interacted with before.
They agreed to that collab, but I don't know.
Maybe I should be a cheeky shite and ask alias.
I don't know.
I feel like it's getting really cheeky now
because I think that would be my 10th ass collab
and only one is up right now.
But it's because I need time to do it.
And I don't, as far as I'm aware,
I don't think any VTuber is like, oh my god,
you've still not done, you've still not sent me your script.
You've still not like edited it together.
I don't think anyone's being cheeky.
I'm like, I think they can see like how hard I'm trying elsewhere.
And I'll get there slowly.
Things will, things will go slowly.
Um, V4, well, I was actually gonna start getting on at them
because Dr. Nova was so nice to me as well.
She was such a cutie, Batuti.
She did like the spit thing with Shibi's mouth
and I was like, that's honestly so creative.
My brain could not even figure out how you did that.
A perfectionist.
Oh no, I'm not a perfectionist.
It's because I've run out of time and I'm mentally exhausted.
Like yesterday, I had a complete like,
um, my body finally broke down,
but in a good way that allowed me to sleep.
So basically I finished the Umi Plus collab
after my three streams that day,
just, just feeling like a little bit of an overachiever there.
Um, and then I did, um, I went straight to bed.
I went straight to sleep.
I slept for about five hours, woke up.
I was like, I need to birth this loaf of bread right effing now.
Did that, had a shower, ordered takeaway as I do normally.
And then I passed out again until Microsoft.
I woke up 10 minutes before Microsoft,
but I've finally had a rest.
Like, I don't feel that exhaustion
that was looming over me for so long.
Like, I don't feel it right now.
I'm so freaking glad.
How's the loaf?
The loaf, um, yes, it's gone.
The loaf is gone.
Well, the spit in the air, she's crazy.
There's a lot of very unique stuff apparently.
Oh, right.
No, no, finally taking care.
It's, things are so, it's because there's so much chaos
and start in the first month,
but now that the first month like is over,
um, we can actually do it.
We can actually do it.
We can actually like achieve all our,
uh, missions and objectives and all of that.
Like, oh, and like fucking hell,
it's been like, well, hold on.
I'm going to open up my YouTube stats right now.
It's been a month of streaming
and I have made 300,000 views on my content.
And the month hasn't even finished.
I mean, hell, maybe even be more to it, you know?
Literally, I am over a quarter of a million views
and I'm a new VTuber and it's been a month.
Like, y'all know, y'all know.
Uh, what does it say for subscribers?
8,600, like it's the first month.
This is insane.
This is insanity.
Um, so I definitely want to start pushing those ASMR videos
out consistently because I don't want to,
I don't want anyone thinking I'm taking like the PS
when I'm doing it, you know?
I thought she was about to say 300,000 dollars.
Well, if I make 300,000 dollars,
I'm happy to say that, yeah,
Gentoon through your end production
and no, I do not need to do a donathon.
But yeah, for my birthday donathon,
which is October 10th,
my goals are pretty much set up to be agency-orientated.
So yeah.
Strangely, if you don't care yourself,
you'll be mad.
P.S.
Considering it's you, I mean, that's surprising.
It's because you put out four times
the average amount of content,
you get tons of views from your consistent viewer base.
For again, I was getting worried,
you guys aren't going to like stuff,
but you always do.
And I'm like, is this what unconditional love feels like?
Oh, my heart.
Oh, it made me cry.
Um, I can't wait to see the birthday
just to play Assassin's Creed Brotherhood again.
Honestly, I'm so, I'm so ready.
Such a hard worker.
I work hard because you guys won't beat me, okay?
Did you see the Sheevee clip
where she talked about all your fan bases,
my wee wifling?
All your wiflings are belong to us.
You're a pretty likable person, thank yous,
because I used to wipe ass in care homes.
I mean, it humbles you very much
when you wipe old lady ass, I have to admit.
Or an old man gets a bone bone
because you're having to change his diaper,
so that's really fun.
It really humbles you.
It really gives you a very unique, strong personality, you know?
Um, you could do a stream of watching paint dry
and I'd probably watch it with you.
Hey, let's do it.
Shawnee, you need to learn that we love you.
We love everything you do.
Darling, that'll be nice to me.
If we miss one stream, we miss a week's worth of yeah
when it's compared to others.
Well, you guys were telling me that people that do,
that have membership,
some people like do one membership stream a month.
I'm like, this is an exchange of goods and services.
You have to make the exchange of goods and services worth it.
Don't you?
All right, don't people move away
if you don't make it worth their time, worth their whale?
I wouldn't get humbled.
I'm more like boosted, to be honest.
I, I don't know if it's because I grew up
looking after like cats and all of that.
Um, that basically any puke cat or shat,
it doesn't really faze me.
And like, yeah, the thing,
probably the thing that grosses me out
is like a decomposing corpse.
That's probably what would gross me out
in terms of like body fluids and stuff.
Like, I don't, this is kind of off topic,
but um, you know,
if you have a dementia patient in your care,
it's actually quite common to do brown smearing,
brown painting, if you will.
It's actually quite common.
Because when you have dementia,
you lose, you don't understand what you're doing.
And it's just a wee shame.
And like when, you know,
for example, when I entered the room,
you know, you go, you get shocked at first
and then you're like, wait,
if I don't clean up this, this person,
you know, they're going to be,
you know, sitting in this situation
and it's not nice.
So you do the right thing
and you know, you put your protective gear on
and you get to work and make sure they're all showered
and fresh sheets and all that.
And you just get to it.
That's, it's just how it is.
It's very straightforward.
I know it can be quite,
quite daunting, I guess,
maybe if the first time you're ever tasked with it,
but it makes you realize like, look, yeah,
okay, it's a bit gross.
Yeah, it doesn't smell nice.
No one's expected it to smell
like marshmallow fluff or whatever.
But yeah, you know, you just,
you just go for it.
You do the right, you do the best you can.
Yeah, dementia decline has actually tried it.
Yeah, it's, it's pretty fucking rough.
I have to admit.
Maui, Maui Gran had a fall
and a lot of sickness followed.
I don't know what it is.
Well, I don't know what it is.
Basically, old person has fall deteriorates rapidly.
More news at three is the most common way
that an old person pops or clogs.
I don't know.
Well, I don't know why
because it's like a shock to the system
and the body can't repair.
I think they say after the age of 30,
your body no longer is growing
and becoming a new.
It's just focusing on repair and maintenance
beyond like 30.
Did anyone paint anything cool?
One, that's funny too.
Shut the fuck up.
The fact that you could do it is commendable.
I've seen the bad parents.
Like honestly, if you ever like have to be the caretaker
of someone with dementia,
don't ever feel bad if you have to put them in a care home.
Like I know there's so many stories
that come out about care homes being bad at this and that.
I promise you at the forefront of care homes,
there are people who genuinely have the willpower
and the care, like they do genuinely care
and try their best.
The problem is the greedy corporations
that purposely understaff entire units.
I think my worst ever shift was like
to people to over 50 residents on one floor.
Like, no, it's not possible.
It's not possible.
So, yeah.
Yeah, as you age, you get worse at healing
and in the case of the elderly,
falling loss of balance is like just,
yeah, like fricking straight up.
Hey, strongy, you done with gaming?
I'm so sorry, MLG did it.
The Microsoft was supposedly supposed to be eight hours,
but that was a game developers assessment.
So they were wrong.
They were wrong.
I've seen nurses in care homes mistreat the elderly.
I would never have put my parents in one.
It's like such a hard balance
because to get at home health is not easy.
It's not cheap.
It's not even viable for a lot of people.
However, I think with the rise
of multi-generational households,
I think that is going to be a very lovely solution.
I would very much like to see in my lifetime
the rise of multi-generational households again
or very close-knit communities again.
Gardening, I'm going to see that picked up
so we start relying on the big supermarkets.
But anyway, before I put my tinfoil hat on,
how about we redirect into mimosa?
I'll get some food in my tum tum
and I will put up my membership ASMR stream
in 10 minutes time.
Give me 10 minutes.
Make a salt was, it was good.
I may have perished in the lava by accident.
And I also bumrushed the last mission, which didn't work.
Did you get your game?
No, the way I type in game and then how long?
So I literally type in mech assault, how long?
And I'm pretty sure if you type it in Google right now,
it says eight hours.
Oh my God, what happens if we type the same thing
on Google at the same time, right?
Mech assault, how long Google?
Main story, seven hours and 44 minutes.
Uh-huh, that's right.
And I did it in five, I think, roughly five.
There's a site called how long to be, exactly.
It's gonna be a membership tinfoil ASMR.
Honestly, it does may take me long.
It does may take me long to get started.
Okay, she's a gamer.
Oh my God, wait, what's this?
What's the speed run?
Mech assault, speed run, world, world record.
Let's see if my, can I be the first person to submit for it?
No, wait, I can be seventh place, shut up.
How can someone defeat the game in 59 minutes?
Whoever the fuck you are, elite two heroes,
I'm coming for your British ass.
Fucking 59 minutes, it took me five hours.
Right, I'm going for seventh place.
I'm gonna submit myself for mech assault, thanks.
And ironically making strongy cuttles right now on speedrun.com.
Speedrunners are insane.
Seventh place gamer, yay, I'm seventh place.
Let's go, seventh place.
I'm just glad we did it.
Let's go.
Oh, elite two, viewer has their YouTube video link.
Ah, I bet you're using cheats.
I'm gonna watch that.
I'm gonna be annoyed.
She's in the top, I'm top seventh on mech assault.
I'll tell my, I can tell my dad that.
Where's my phone?
Oh, my phone's not here.
I'll tell my dad that I got the seventh world record
on mech assault purely on the basis
that no one has submitted for it.
And then he'll be mega proud of me.
I just checked and it's seven.
Yeah, hell yeah.
Okay, right, before I continue yappening
all your ears off again.
So yeah, literally top 10, same top,
maybe I won't say seventh, I'll say top 10.
I'll be like, I'll talk, I'm top 10 speaker on record me,
but what do you mean?
And I'll be like, yes, well,
I'm gonna watch him take first place tomorrow, honestly.
He would probably do that way faster than me.
Right, as I said, I'm gonna end stream.
It's gonna redirect you into mimosa.
For those of you who are a member of Strony Cottle's channel,
I am about to take a 10 minute rest
to get some food in my belly.
And then we're gonna do membership ASMR.
And I'll get all booted up for that, okay?
So I will see you tomorrow for some Beltro,
which is two hours later,
or I will see you in 10 minutes for membership ASMR.
Thank you so so much for keeping me company
through an insane childhood game,
a childhood game, so childhoody,
that I actually wasn't even able to play it at the time
because I was so small and tiny.
Okay, imagine checking the speed runner list
and finding you lost to a watermelon cuttlefish, honestly.
Okay, right, bye-bye.
Thank you so much for the stream, Reflanks.
I'll see you very very shortly.
And have a nice day.
Remember to hydrate and eat and stretch
so you don't have any problems with your booty hole.
Okay?
Bye, Reflanks.
See you tomorrow.
Bye.
Are you gonna tongue it?
Imagine if I said goodbye like that.
Oh, my spit's going everywhere.
Sorry, I'm salivating.
Sorry.
Okay, bye.
See you on mimosa or see you in 10 minutes.